We have so much to talk about today.
I can barely get through these fucking commercials.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by 1-800-FLOWERS.
Now,
I make a big risk in saying this episode of the Joe Rogan Experience,
since my name is Joe Rogan,
and everybody knows that saying your name,
the full name,
okay,
that's a douchey thing to do.
Why do you mean?
If you were like Brennan Shab will be the heavyweight champ of the world.
Brendan Schaub knows how to train.
Brendan Schaub has tremendous cardio.
People are like,
why the fuck is Brendan Shop?
St His own when you're talking about is how in the third person is an issue.
So you can't take the job.
It's my fucking experience.
It's your experience.
I can't say,
did Joe Rogan,
who did I?
Every time I say that somebody aligned Callen show,
I cringe.
I apologize afterwards.
This is the experience from now on.
All right,
whatever.
This is the,
anyway,
we're brought to you by 1-800-FLOWERS.
It's almost mother's Day.
You little freakazoids.
You know the deal,
man,
your mom made you.
She built you inside of her vagina and you should be super kind to her.
I don't know anything about science.
I do.
It's in the vagina.
You got to go through the vagina and the KSG gates of heaven.
It's science.
It is science.
And uh,
your mom is awesome and your mom made you and your awesome mom would love some
awesome flowers and now is the time to send her the best.
This mother's Day.
A beautiful bouquet bouquet.
I love to use this.
Where's there's sound different?
A bouquet of roses.
Why don't we have an American work for Booz k?
It's a fucking bundle.
Okay.
Do you know that 60% of all,
uh,
English words are,
French origins.
So makes sense.
Bouquets an English word,
right?
Yeah.
So you,
you actually like a,
anything with that,
like most of front,
most,
most 60% of franchises I think derived from English.
That's the first night I teach when he was learning French
military.
Anyway,
beautiful bouquet of roses from one 800 flowers.com.
Go get that shit for your mom's son.
That's the one thing I always envied about black guys.
They got to say,
my mom's my mom anyway.
Yeah.
You know how my mom's is always telling me you got to get done my homework.
If you're white,
if you're white,
you're white.
You talk like that.
Don't call me anymore.
It's a very good point.
Yeah.
Anyway,
Gay Moms,
some beautiful flowers.
1-800-FLOWERS right now.
They're having an incredible offer for my listeners available until Friday,
May 2nd only until Friday,
May 2nd you can order a dozen multicolored roses and receive an additional dozen
roses in a vase.
Said was that French word?
Vas?
A vase.
Vases.
Vases on glass.
So I'll say one more time.
It doesn't multicolored roses.
You can get an additional dozen roses and a vase for only 29 99 phase or vibes.
I don't know.
I think it depends on where you live.
That's a full boot.
K of 24 roses and a vase
with both faces is extra checks.
This is 50% off the regular price.
Ladies and gentlemen,
order now.
Got a one 800 flowers.com from your desktop or mobile device.
Click on the radio microphone in the upper right hand corner and enter J r e
that's one 800 flowers.com and enter in j r e or call 1-800-FLOWERS and
mentioned jre.
There it is,
year Britches.
A lot of times it doesn't.
Roses cost you $5,000 not with one 800 and get cost you your life cause she a
house picking up your flowers for your mother footy a mum were also brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com it's o n n I t a company that makes shit,
I promise.
I will eventually send to Brian Cowen and Brennan Shop.
Yeah,
thanks a lot man.
I'll give you my address.
Just trying to get sweat,
man.
It's all about emails.
Send me an email,
send me an email with your address and I'll find it on
my friend.
I got a grand baby
but he's got man,
what the fuck you can forward it to your guy.
He may owe.
You know what to do.
An email.
You know how to do it about broken,
supple and narrow.
I want to get thick.
I want to grow from east to west.
You got to start lifting,
lifting and heavy and you've got to eat a lot of elk,
some elk steaks.
Almost done with my my deer.
Eat some bare burger.
Eat some bare burger and workout exclusively with the 72 pounds.
Zombie kettle bells.
Preparing for the apocalypse.
You can do it,
dude.
You want to champion?
Absolutely.
Fuck yeah.
Alpha brain.
I want to champion.
How many are in there?
Left?
I got a whole box
anyway.
alright.com use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Did they have anything for your neck when you pull it?
Shampooing your hair.
It's called dude,
I told my neck.
I just want the listeners know I was shampooing my hair this morning.
Sham point,
maybe a little too vigorously and my neck out of out of sorts.
You're for sure.
Using what?
How do you do that?
You're doing bad things.
Whatever you do and God's punishing you because I was trained and it used the
Codeword Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements.
Brendan Shop,
Brian Counter,
both here so by puck around shop get bigger than me.
He's in a tank top.
Look at that.
Well,
good experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Love sizing you up as it gets older is getting more thin,
more feminine,
more gay.
Were up there talking about it.
What we're playing pool was talking about,
I don't even like to eat food anymore.
It's because your body is preparing you to become this wave,
like older games.
My sister and my sister looked at me and she goes,
you know you got a came when I go,
why?
She goes,
because you look like one of those fish in a polluted lake.
Yeah,
that's big.
Your body's getting,
I was like,
what are you,
I'm the same way.
She goes,
no,
you're not.
You got to start eating shoved food.
You're a dime piece for the,
for the gay community for sure.
I was just with Jimmy Burke in New York with gay men.
I was at the duplex surrounded by gay men.
No looks,
I got nothing.
That's when you know you're getting old.
It's about the other hand walk
around,
Dude.
You don't walk around like you're,
you've got possessed.
I wasn't walking around and you're uncomfortable and worried about how they're
proceeding because my neck hurts.
That's why you hurt yourself.
Yeah,
exactly.
My chest,
I heard myself shaving my chest.
You hurt your neck when you're shampooing your hair.
The bottom I'd say in the gay community,
I think just the brush up from the bottom.
A lot of gay men are just way more muscular.
I was walking down West Hollywood.
I was literally the guy who looked like he had rickets.
I didn't appreciate it.
Let's Hollywood's a different bird.
My first week living here,
I was walking down West Hollywood.
Never been there,
right?
Yeah.
Going down there was not familiar.
It was Gainesville is,
I do not care,
but yeah,
I have a tank top on it cause I just got done working out doing boxes over there
to walk around without a tank top on.
Once you boxing,
especially if you know you're going to be in a gay neighborhood neighborhood.
That's what I'm saying.
Or fight for America.
Yeah.
I was going to say you were walking around with like with a tank top because you
were in your experimental phase.
There's things you have to do and sometimes you just gotta sometimes like
playing hard to get,
it was on the bucket list.
Oh boy.
Likes to play horse girls that we'll put on a short skirt and high heels.
You'd if they have a man,
they just,
they want it.
They want us to feel it out.
Everyone know that you know the business might be closed down to the public,
but it's large shop knows the size of every one of his friends.
Dick's,
I can guarantee he investigates.
That's a question he asks.
He's like,
Hey,
he's gay.
He's an honest man.
Uncomfortable.
Yeah.
It's honest man and he likes talking about boy stuff,
but I,
I was in West Hollywood.
Richard Simmons pulls up and Alexis in full costume goes.
If I had one wish you'd be to be with you for at night.
I didn't know he had a southern accent,
but,
well,
I,
that's probably the best money I've ever heard.
I don't know.
I don't know how to do it.
I didn't want to do it.
My findings,
I don't want to do my voice.
I don't even know if that's like,
if it's possible that that came out of your mouth.
I feel like I'm getting,
that was weird,
right?
You feel like,
I feel like
I've actually watched him a number of tasks.
Talking over at James Scott,
he's louder and he's excited.
There you go.
That's Richard Simmons.
I don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
I heard what you said,
which I was looking over to see if Jamie was so high that worked in the buttons.
Slipping it in there.
I was shocked.
I'm shocked.
My experience with less Hollywood,
really flamboyantly gay exercise instructors.
Look at Richard Simmons and go,
I don't fucking get,
it.
Ain't about me.
What about me?
By the way,
by the way,
has a bad fire,
but he feels like he's built like a CPA.
I've never seen this,
that skinny fat build,
these huge Afros as muscular as your average librarian.
We,
you know,
I had Steve Maxwell in here the other day,
the strength and conditioning coach,
Kettlebell Guy,
he's a Zach Maxwell's dad who's a top flight Jujitsu fighter today.
These days on one of the only guys would be Kron Gracie,
Zach Maxwell's a real beast.
He's Dad,
Steve Maxwell.
That's like been my kettle bell instructor and friend for years cause out of La.
Um,
he's well,
he's got the craziest life ever,
man.
He's not out of La.
He's out of everywhere.
He travels all over the world.
He goes here,
he goes there.
I don't remember the original point.
What you just talking about.
We're talking about uh,
being muscular and versus like Richard Simmons who's built like a crossfit
instructor.
That's what it is.
He introduced me to the guy who invented crossfit.
I didn't know the guy in Ventura.
Glas fit is fat.
Well Greg had like,
he's not even,
he's not even remotely shade now cause he got a gut.
I can't listen to that.
Have you seen it?
No,
but if of big fact I was trying to tell me how to lift,
I'm going to be like,
Nah,
I'm cool bro.
Look at this.
Look at this image of this guy.
No,
but that's because of that.
Greg has a set of tits.
No,
he had polio when he was young and one of his legs is much smaller than the
other and so it's hard.
Oh,
it's right.
so he has titties because of it.
No,
but he can't,
he can't exercise the way you would be able to because he has,
he had polio and he's partially paralyzed cupcakes.
He does now.
He knows what he does.
Is He,
um,
he was a really good gymnast when he was younger,
but because he's got issues with his back,
his spine,
he,
that,
that's,
that's how it's hard for him and I call bullshit.
That's enlightening.
But it seems like he's overeating and for sure it's diet.
I mean,
if you're,
he's obviously he was walking around,
right?
Walks around.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
you're right.
This is a crossfit.
We're not talking about the guy who was the head of Arby's.
Okay.
We're talking about the guys,
the head of,
Oh look at that.
I mean if that'd be in health and slash or are you going to listen?
Maybe,
maybe knows.
Things like there's some people that are really good coaches that never really
fought,
right?
There's people who are like students of all sorts of different things,
whether it's athletic movements and they don't possess any physical talent.
It's a super,
super common thing.
In fact,
people become fans of football.
No more about football than football players who are professional.
Right?
That's a fact.
Absolutely.
Same thing with them.
And look at your average coach and football.
Oh for sure.
And they're there.
Rex Ryan and those guys are just way out of shape.
Tony,
I mean,
you know,
perfect example,
true.
But in football,
some of those linemen are big boys out of shape.
So you can,
you can see that.
The point is you can know what is saying.
You can know he got them to sky size without,
without um,
being the walking embodiment of exercise.
Right?
But look at all those other people Jamie just threw up.
There's other people that are all fitness instructors.
Look at that.
That's what they're supposed to look like.
That guy,
the third one,
index to the blonde hot chick.
He tells me something to do.
I'm going to do it.
He says that John won't say how high,
but guys,
abs are ridiculous.
[inaudible] listening to the guy who's that feed out.
Just find that strange.
Well,
when they say,
give us your best pick and you do that,
I'm not going to,
I don't think he's that flexible.
They're,
they're all fine for me.
I like it.
Yeah.
You don't want to have one on ones with the girl though.
She's too hot.
I'm too close to,
I don't want your wife trained with a male personal trainer.
No,
there I did it.
A bodybuilder girl is she and Gold's gym.
I met her and she was a bodybuilder,
but natural and so hot and I put in my eye and her boyfriend,
her ex boyfriend was a bodybuilder in the gym and he,
he'd give me this,
these terrible,
he just walk around just in Gold's and grunting and really mad at me and just
just hating me cause he still liked her.
It was such an uncomfortable thing,
but I know what a good top and is,
isn't it the best when you're around a guy who's a bitch,
you can't get over a check.
So he gets mad at you because you liked the checklist.
Oh,
glorious.
Those men are so important just to know that there's bitches like that out
there.
I just know there's men who just are not men do mass great preacher curls,
like concentration curls,
eh,
eh.
And I was like,
all right,
no problem.
Your only problem is that you both think that the same person is awesome.
That's the only problem.
It's not like you beat her up.
It's not like you stole money from her.
It's not like you took his car and threw it in the river as well,
but just a competition.
But to the meat heads,
the fence,
he was probably trying to make it work.
And then you come in with this big spot.
There's no defense,
there's no defense.
I bitch is a bitch.
You know,
you gotta,
you gotta deal with your position in life and if a girl likes someone else and
you grovel and you tried to get her back or you get upset at the guy,
you're a bit,
well the other thing,
the other thing is I was like,
I was on mad TV at the time and he wanted to be an actor.
He wanted to be the next,
it wasn't gonna happen.
This guy sounds like a winner.
Just like,
dude,
you're better looking relaxed.
You've gotta,
you know,
you're more muscular if you're into that.
There's nothing wrong with other guys.
Login the same check you like.
It's just this life is fucking short.
If guys don't like your chicken,
you're dating an ugly chick.
It's also,
there's too many Sandra Bullock movies and just dude run around out there that
think that there's a gal out there.
That's the one.
This is [inaudible] more on the talk.
She was the one Brendan,
Brendan,
I fucking drank with.
That girl was shit out by the fucking porch.
It was like a Bruce Springsteen song.
We would drink wine to go to and even tried to fuck up bro.
I ain't even tried to fuck her.
I didn't want to ruin something.
That's my favorite.
It's not going to Joe and I go like this,
like,
I don't know.
I gotta think I gotta break up,
but I love her and he goes,
NATO and that we start talking.
I got,
well,
I got what you don't think I,
I don't,
you don't think I love it?
He goes,
Nah,
definitely not.
Anyway,
so,
and he wouldn't even give it any time.
It just goes,
no,
you don't.
I go,
no,
no.
But I think I do is not,
no,
I go,
you don't think I love her.
He's not.
Anyway,
so,
and he just could change something and kept rolling forward.
He wasn't going to hear me.
He would try to convince himself that he loves somebody and she was the most
insane relationships and he's like,
this is all I love.
It's a love.
I love her.
I go,
no,
you don't.
You don't look.
Do you want to eat?
You want to go get somebody?
I was like blowing it off.
He would just literally gave it no entertainment.
None.
You're not in love with her.
Stop.
Listen to yourself.
Do you want to,
you have to stop lying to yourself in in life and you as you get older,
you stopped doing that hopefully,
or you become a crazy person,
but you have to.
You have to confront who you're pretending to be and and the lies you tell
yourself.
It's so important.
It's tough when you're younger though,
you're like on this grind.
Like for me,
I'm on this grind.
I'm married to the UFC,
so girls,
they become it there.
They play second fiddle,
the UFC.
I made the UFC and she can be a real bitch,
you know what I'm saying?
She
talked to deal with sometimes and you health is on the line,
your consciousness is on the line.
She says fish actually super salvage.
I can't go to your family's barbecue on a Saturday cause I gotta chill and
recovering train,
isn't it all?
So don't you find as an elite athlete that you have to be really conscious of
your mindset and what you think about now?
I mean if you're weak minded,
think about what
the psychology,
the psychology of like when you train for Lawsky the psychology of staying
positive,
not negative.
It's what mean
you have to risk that when you get involved in a relationship.
Cause oftentimes relationships go bad and some of the worst times you could ever
have in the gym will come right after you got in a big fight with your girl.
You just can't concentrate and you get,
I've had that happen before.
It happens.
Why you don't deal with chicken heads.
That's what I mean.
You gotta be disciplined about the people you surround yourself with.
Well I won't even entertain the idea of a chicken head chicken that comes along.
I'm like,
no,
keep,
keep clucking get out.
So you wouldn't date the girl that was with sterling,
the ultimate chicken edge.
She deserves a trophy.
They all commit chicken out of all time.
The La Clippers has great,
listen,
if someone said,
you're going to bang this chick,
you're gonna lose the fucking Los Angeles Clippers if you hang out with this big
thinking about that,
the biggest chicken hen of all time,
he lost the team because it's chick.
Take all the racism out.
Whatever.
He's a racist bastard,
right?
Sucks.
They should not be that way.
Granted,
if he never signed up for this chicken head,
he would still own the Los Angeles.
Click upbeat.
And not only that,
do you know the whole story behind it?
The wife,
his wife was suing this girl for embezzling money that the,
the,
uh,
the man sterling had clearly given this chick.
He wanted to give her some things about gifts and stuff.
I bought her gifts and so the wife was trying to take back the gifts so she was
sooner and that's when the,
the Cha,
the tape magically revealed.
He sounds a little drunk in the tape probably.
He's lit up.
He came home from a fucking dinner,
had a couple of drinks in him.
Can you imagine the next morning he sobered up and was like,
what?
It's totally illegal by the way.
You can't just record something.
Yeah.
Not In California.
She's saying they're saying two things.
The same.
One that she didn't record it.
Somebody else recorded it and just saying to that he was aware that he was being
recording both.
Nowadays it's not a chance.
Bolted.
Preposterous.
Yeah.
You're actually not allowed in California,
I think without the consent of the purse.
Two parties,
two parties,
consent.
You know what he needs to do because he needs to go around the nation.
He needs to make positive out of this and it needs to be how to avoid chicken
heads one on one.
He is the ultimate face with chicken heads.
Well,
I don't know about clippers because of the,
yeah,
but he's going to,
he only bought the clippers for 12 million bucks.
It's worth a half a billion deal.
Smart businessman,
sal.
It's where the half a billion now.
Everyone's trying to buy.
Oprah is trying to buy it.
Right.
Floyd Mayweather.
Meanwhile,
he's suing the,
he's suing the NBA.
Oh,
he's not going to go.
He's suing them for billions of dollars.
He was a divorce lawyer case.
No,
in a stranger.
He's no stranger to the litigation.
He was divorced.
Can't
just fucking do that to someone because of a private conversation that was
illegally wiretap.
You can't do that.
Yeah.
Even though they're assholes,
even though he's an asshole,
you can't do that because who knows what his state of mind is.
He shouldn't have to protect his state of mind and wonder if it was going to be
public.
If it's in a private moment,
if he wants to say something completely inappropriate because he's drunk and
then once it cancels and in his own house and then wants to recanted the next
day or feel the folly of his ways or feel bad about what he said and correct
himself or not,
he still what he says publicly,
she'd be public statements and this idea that you're supposed to pretend that
everyone is listening to you and watching you every minute is ridiculous.
It's unfair.
It's unprecedented.
And you're talking about an old man who is probably barely understanding what's
going on.
The Internet was invented when he was 61 fucking years old.
Wrap your head around that.
Okay.
20 years ago,
1994 what will,
what kind of internet?
We have some dog shit.
Aol Internet 61 then no idea you have use.
It's chicken,
but you have the shoes and the hard case to listen.
You got to do what you gotta do when you're old man.
You want to fuck young pussy.
You're not going to get chicks that are balanced.
She's not even not hot to plenty.
Plenty out.
What he told me,
you know,
and she looked at him for have looked at him,
have you seen,
have you looked at is have you looked at his team?
He owns the Los Angeles Clippers.
Hasn't mattered if he looks like an elephant's balls that's been stuffed into
the shape of a man.
He's,
he's ancient horse though.
I've seen where it's go the fig and olive in Hollywood,
you're see some old dudes with some young chicks,
playboy mansion.
Oh my God.
That's a gift.
He's an old guy and she's young girl and them's the rules.
Okay,
let's not pretend it isn't anything other than what it is.
Look at that.
That's what it is,
man.
That's what it's been since the beginning of time.
She's planning.
He does look like hot and melted cheese.
Not that hot.
Can we get a better picture?
I was.
He stopped Dabo.
Listen,
Brendan,
beauty and the beast of all.
First of all,
you are dealing with a totally different class of human.
So let's just drop that.
Okay?
You're
right.
You're right.
You're right and hot to an old dude that looks like an elephant's balls that has
been shaped into,
doesn't matter,
doesn't matter when you own the clippers.
Bitches are lining up taking money.
Two things.
You have taken some iteration.
One,
as you get older,
you'll give less,
less a fuck about a girl being perfect.
And that's why MILF porn exists.
You want dirty old chicks that are just,
fuck it.
Let's give up.
And they're,
they're all weird.
Looks [inaudible] keep their ones shocking.
Rare.
It looks at me.
We were talking to these,
these proof us and we're there.
The couple of 21 year old girls,
I don't know how old they were there with this hanging around and,
and um,
he's peeing and he goes and those girls and I was like,
yeah,
they look pretty hot to me.
And he goes,
no,
because at my age,
a girl can have a goat head if she's that age and she's got a body like that,
I don't care if she's got a goat head.
I still think she's hot.
Your standards,
you're not,
you know,
you're,
you're
not looking at symmetry on the level that you are when you're 84 or whatever he
is.
Hot seats.
A hot chick.
First of all,
you want to own the clippers.
You're pulling some.
Okay.
It tells not bad.
Listen,
she,
he can't see.
Okay.
Do you know what it's fucking vision must be like cats must be ridiculous.
His vision must be ridiculous.
It has to do with Joe used to do,
don't Joe used to do this this bit that I think ties to this day to me is maybe
the funny,
one of the funniest things I've ever seen.
It was Hugh Hefner takings Viagara like tic tacs and the girls trying to psych
themselves up to have sex with them and,
and the one girl is like easy.
I can see,
I can see white hair coming out of his ass.
She got a hold your hair.
Don't worry.
He'll get you in the audition,
but Baywatch just go in there.
He's like lucky,
lucky,
lucky.
Please stop.
No,
oh no.
It's all been,
I don't even remember how that,
because I was so good dude.
I talked to white American women on his ass.
I talked to a playmate.
We had the discussion because I said,
it's a little weird to me and she goes,
what's weird?
I go,
well these girls,
what was the show on e that they have girls next door.
I said the show girls next door.
This old dude in these three hot blondes.
It's kind of,
it's just weird.
She goes,
what's weird?
I go,
well,
obviously they're not in into it because the way it looks,
they're just didn't do it to purse,
you know,
better their careers.
And she goes,
oh no,
he's a great guy.
He takes care of us ball.
I'm like,
it's weird.
I said,
what's your dad say about it?
She was,
oh,
I don't have a dad.
That's a given.
I could have told you that.
Yeah,
it's a lot of that.
They don't have a real male role model maybe or someone who looks at the
situation and goes,
hey,
this is my little daughter.
Why is she with this old man?
What?
What have I done wrong to make her lean towards?
It's really old guy,
but I'm not,
I'm not hating on Hugh Hefner.
I'm hating on the girls.
I will do your thing.
I'm
definitely not hate on the girls because the girls,
a lot of them,
like girls who get into that situation,
whether they're,
they're taking naked pictures or doing porn or you know,
almost all of them,
they come from a situation somewhere early on in their life where someone did
something bad to them.
You know,
it's a super common thing.
It's not all of them.
There's a lot of girls who don't,
but they,
the percentages girls,
no.
Yes.
Play mates,
I don't think,
well,
I think that that is a very similar,
like I don't think there's anything wrong with either one.
I should be real clear about that.
Like,
I don't want to take photographs naked,
do something wrong.
There's nothing wrong with having sex on video.
There's nothing wrong with any of it.
But a lot of people that associate like their sexuality with how they express
themselves or their sexuality exclusively,
how they promote and present themselves.
Like sometimes it comes from a place where they were abused somewhere else.
That makes me sad.
So when I see,
you know,
and I'm not necessarily saying that that happened,
those girls are with Haffner but when I see,
no,
I think those girls are opportunists.
They might be,
but they might not be.
They might,
he might really be the first guy that was ever like super sweet and they knew
that he was going to support them.
It's super possible like you shake your head like that,
but totally true.
Like
if you're a chick and you're really vulnerable.
If I'm a chick and I'm the prom king or you know what I'm saying,
the Prom Queen of the Prom Queen,
I get done.
I have,
I don't have shit to do.
Right?
I'm like what am I gonna do?
I'm a hot chick.
What am I do playboy?
Well sign me up Mattson.
100 could be animation and then you do maximum 100 and that's like,
all right,
well let's step our game up.
Let's get these titties,
I'll get more money.
Great.
Now making money,
just showing my titties and it goes from there.
Let's throw a dicon now you're doing porno.
That's the vicious cycle.
I don't know.
Cause I just had to us that Kira on the podcast,
she wrote that book,
I'm insatiable.
She,
you know she is.
Yeah,
totally.
And it was really interesting conversation because I kept trying to find out
like kind of what would the origin of doing this was because she does like you
know nine guys and all that.
And she said actually she very very self aware because the book was really funny
actually and kind of interesting in how open she was about how destructive this
was going to be for her future in certain ways.
Like having kids,
never working with kids.
And I said,
what do you think it was that caused you to take this jump?
Cause she's really very self aware.
I go,
you probably could have been successful at a lot of things because you're pretty
smart and you know and and you,
she came from a pretty tight family and she said,
you know,
honestly I don't know.
I don't know what it was that got me to take this step cause I knew full well
and still do that.
The repercussions.
A lot of which I can never walk away from this.
You have a boyfriend?
Yes.
She's married to a guy in the business course.
Could you be married to a Bordeaux?
No.
Could you do it,
Jill?
Be Tough.
Action.
You'd have to have a strong mind.
Plus people don't know why they do what they do.
And I don't know that it says cut and dry as saying,
well you know,
most of the time I think it's probably damaged somewhere.
I do think there are examples where people are okay.
The Armani suit example you talked to Darin Diorama on,
she didn't have any abuse or childhood.
She's a very healthy attitude about the whole thing.
She's a very smart chick too.
Interesting to talk about it.
Cause uh,
you know,
she sorta disposes the myth and you know,
all those myths.
What's the matter?
Things blocking just face who's thing?
Okay.
Well maybe we should move to cameras.
Sorry.
Where were we?
You were talking about,
uh,
about,
porn,
porn stars and damage and,
and being self aware.
I forgot my point.
So it's just fucking,
yeah,
it doesn't matter the,
you know,
the bottom line is there's a lot of them.
Whatever the percentages where it's 40% and 50% a lot of it comes from damage.
So that's how I look at it.
Like I always feel bad,
I feel sorry for him.
Sure.
I have daughters too,
so I see what it's,
I think there's a,
and I have a sister,
it's a very different thing growing up being a chick,
it's a different world man.
You know,
it's uh,
my bed,
honorable guy can be strong gay guys hitting on us and I like last night I went
to go get vegetables late at night,
which is weird.
Anyways,
I go to get vegetables in Marina del Rey and I'm walking by this frozen yogurt
place and these two guys are making out,
which is whatever,
you just don't see it a lot.
So I was like,
oh
damn.
That's the way they kept me looking at them.
They stare at me,
they make some smart comment under their breath.
I was like,
man,
just look forward.
Just keep moving.
Like super nervous.
And then I thought this owl hot chicks feel all the time,
even with real shitty looking dudes are getting no matter what they're always
getting hit on.
I'll give you one more,
I'll give you one more.
If you are with your check,
your check wouldn't feel threatened by two dudes that were in to you.
But if you were a hot chick and you were,
that's disrespectful.
That's difference.
Disrespectful.
Oh,
it's definitely different swagger.
But if you're,
if you're a hot chick and you were the guy that can't defend you and there's a
bunch of big scary guys are hitting on you,
that's even worse.
It's an even worse situation.
So to be a check like it least,
you don't have to worry about yourself physically,
like most likely.
And think about how nervous you got.
You're a UFC fighter and those two guys,
I was just like,
I know that they're gonna hold me down and write my ass.
Right.
But think about that.
You are physically dominant over them.
100% it's still in.
It still felt uncomfortable.
That's dark shit,
man.
So you think about what it's like to be a 100 pound girl and there's three or
four dudes who look like you and they're buying yogurt and you're trying to get,
can I get that bake and Yay.
Yes.
A Bacon Bitch
fucking cause these giants like a gazelle among lions can't run away from,
I'm not going as fast.
It's very rare you get thick cock ogres banding up and raping guys in the
fucking salad bar.
Especially in Marina del Rey.
Yeah.
People always want to say that like,
you know,
like there's a guy that I had on the podcast had actually tried to make that
argument.
He was like,
well,
you know the statistics on rape are very deceptive because a lot of people don't
know that more men are raped.
Then women's right.
And I go,
yeah,
but you know who's raping the men?
Other men.
So it's fucking stupid.
Like what Kinda dumb ass point is that other men are raping men.
It's not like women or raping men who gets raped.
More men or women.
You'd be surprised at the outcome.
I also don't believe that by that of course it is present in prison.
A lot of guys are getting raped in prison and you factor nozzle guys are getting
raped.
That's just a fact.
Especially if you consider rape,
like there are things that people are considering rape now that really wasn't
considered rape when we were younger.
What are we talking about?
We're talking about a lot of different things.
You said getting a girl drunk and and yeah,
to get you in trouble.
Getting a girl drunk,
getting your lot
jail,
who spent a lot of time in jail.
And one of the things they all said is that I go,
what about the right thing?
And they go,
you know man,
a lot of that he goes,
you got to realize is that there are a lot of guys in jail willing to give it up
for free.
And so if you are the kind of guy who,
if they know that they're going to,
they're going to have to fight for it and you might lose an eye or a nose.
Dude,
they go,
let's just go over to the [inaudible].
Know what I'm saying?
They'll go,
great,
they'll,
they'll actually leave you on the phone and the other guy,
oh,
no,
no.
What he's saying is that if you're willing to fight,
they won't fuck you and the,
but that's still rape,
dude,
you fought back.
I still rate the other guy who gives him
out of fear for his life.
He's getting raped.
I was also watching a prison and the guy was saying this gangster was saying,
Nah,
it's not gay man,
because when you're in prison,
all rules are off.
Know when I get out,
I'm back with my girl.
Yeah.
They call me,
they call it gave for the stage.
Do you remember what Shane Carlin said to me?
I looked at him.
I go,
God,
I gotta look.
And I go,
oh,
well,
I don't even know what I do.
If I had a share a prison cell with you.
And he looked at me and he goes,
you'd suck my cock.
I
remember when he picked me up and start squeezing me and I go,
she goes,
he goes,
in my ear,
that's 40% bro.
Yeah.
Another level,
a name mark or I go,
cause he do that to you and Nate goes,
if I let them,
yeah,
it's strong man.
He could squeeze you for death.
The poor guy,
it's really too bad that he had all these injuries,
man.
I have a lot of neck injuries,
a lot of back injuries,
slip ball,
wrestling,
clobbers the Glover.
I'm incredible performance by John Jones.
Smartest shit to that shoulder wrench that he used in the quench.
Amazing.
I've never seen anybody do that before and everyone's going to start doing it
now.
I mean now it's 100% because that comes up all the time.
Guys are copycat league.
I was still in more elbows on Monday.
Sure.
My coach goes,
listen,
I want you to put an elbow pads on now.
You know John,
so good at those two.
In those tight situations.
It doesn't have a,
it doesn't make it an advantage or a disadvantage rather to have long arms when
he's using elbows and he has all the Torque from his mechanical advantage of the
way his body,
his friend,
he's throwing nasty elbows inside the clinch and it's literally the perfect
distance for like full power shots.
Whereas I give you is punching.
You'd have to like get some room in order to punch,
but he's landing these elbows inside and they're just perfect.
What's amazing,
what makes John the best pound for pound fighter in the world right now is you
would think he was just going to sit on the outside and pick glow vertex here
apart and that was the game plan and then he goes,
I just decided to switch it up,
do his game because we thought most experts thought it'd be inside against the,
if it goes inside against the cage,
Glover,
that's where he wants to be is going to tear John Up.
John said,
forget this,
pins him against the cage and just does work.
He did Glover's game plan against him just like he did Charles game plan against
shale.
You know,
it was crazy,
but something I saw you saying something,
uh,
during the,
during the fight was something wrong with his right hand?
No,
never.
Never found out an upper cut,
but that's really,
that's it.
He threw a few.
Oh,
he definitely nothing new.
Nothing like normal.
Right through a lot of laughs.
He threw some nice left hooks to man his left toe check.
Left Hooks.
Yes.
Very nice.
Real accurate.
Left.
Tooks but it was the elbows.
I agree with you up against the cage.
They were the most in my ass.
My feeling is it's going to always be Gustafson.
Gustafson is gonna be number two or whatever.
They're going to battle out again.
And I want to see,
I think the,
the number two spot is up for grabs between Anthony Rumble,
Johnson and Glover to sharer.
Those guys can't sleep on Daniel Cormier.
Man.
Sleep.
That's true.
So true.
Tell me something special.
Not About him.
You can't fuck with Daniel Cormier.
He's something special,
but is he going to be able to deal with John Jones?
We'll we're going to find out.
That's for damn sure.
Yeah.
I think Daniel Cormier is the most marketable God to fight better wrestler John.
He's not just well Gustafson for sure.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I'd say it probably even good points,
but I thought,
I mean outside the Gustafson fights guaranteed that's the next fight might be
outside of that.
That's going to be the next fight,
the next fight with,
with,
with John Judge that for sure.
Gustafson took a big chance to and fight and Jimmy Manoa took a big chance.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
I mean he,
he beat him and he won.
He Won.
But man was no joke.
Man was fucking dangerous.
He's dangerous.
He's very hard plosive fighter.
However,
it was way too much of a jump for him.
Fight and gusts.
Finn was like,
it was Kinda like,
here's here at Guttman stay act.
That's super easy to say after the fact.
But if Gustafson came in,
he wasn't disciplined.
He doesn't mind his p's and q's.
You wouldn't be where he's at if he was it your true,
you're right.
But sometimes guys will slip when they go from a title fight and they dropped
down the next fight there on the fight card.
But he believed he won the fight.
He's the champ and John says same thing too.
He goes Alexander's talking like he won the fight.
It was a great fight but drop it,
you lost.
It was a very good fight.
But I agree with the decision too.
I agree.
It was a,
it was the right decision.
I John Three to two.
Yeah.
John pulled it out and he pulled it out yet he,
and he gutted it out like a champion in the last rounds but jam Gustafson
fucking held himself.
He held account of himself very well.
John Down,
Dean Gustavson after that fight in the hallway cause I went down to the press
conference and and seeing how beat up he was and then seeing John Edge,
I didn't see John after the fight.
Oh John came through my locker room.
You did.
He,
he was on a stretcher.
Is Body who's trembling?
I actually leaned over and I said,
man,
that was a hell of a fight,
man.
I'm so proud of you.
I mean,
my coach Tony Jeffries,
he came from boxing,
right?
Olympic boxer.
That's the first UFC event he's ever been to,
was cornering me.
He's never been to one.
He's never watched one on TV.
That was the first one he sees John.
He goes,
I've never seen anything like that.
He was,
I would never do this after seeing that.
That's well,
he was pushed to the limit and that fight,
man,
that was the limit.
I mean they both have both those guys hit the wall,
but John just kept pushing.
I'll just a little bit more.
Let me just very close by just a little bit more.
I think the sides,
DC and gusts,
Finn,
I don't see anyone challenging John.
I would like to see what happens with Anthony Rumble Johnson though.
Well,
he's going to fight.
I think the fight between those two is as clover to share I level.
Yeah.
They seem very similar styles.
Glover's hurt.
Glovis shoulder's fucked.
He might have to have surgery.
Yeah,
he's shoulder's fucked up.
The fight,
his arm was straight because he was getting that.
He was getting like that right away from the cage.
First round against the cage.
Talking about the beginning.
He doesn't even listen.
We were talking about the shoulder ranch and he was like,
Hey,
when do I get to talk?
Oh No,
I thought you were talking about the not solar winds.
I thought you were talking about when he,
when he uses his shoulder.
No,
no,
no.
Just submission.
You're talking about when he caught his arm and he yanked at this way,
John grabbed his arm,
they tied up and John grabbed his arm.
That's not it either tied up.
John grabbed his arm going along,
yanked his shoulder up and pop it out and you'd
be fucked.
His right arm up dope man.
It was dope.
I love seeing that stuff.
That's so inspiring man.
That's what you were talking about earlier,
that it's a copycat business and you're writing a lot of ways.
The NFL is a copycat business.
So in the NFL,
I'm going to get nerdy on you,
hear some football talk the Tampa too.
So when the uh,
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers won the championship with their defense,
they had a defense called the Tampa to where the middle backer would drop you so
athletic you drop back deep into coverage,
which was rare.
The next year every team was doing it.
Tampa won a championship doing that the next year every team had that defense.
Well now that the offense of figure it out,
no one's doing that anymore.
And the UFC,
same thing.
You see Anthony Pettis using the cage jumping off of it,
we see John Jones stone elbows.
Guess what?
I guarantee you I wasn't the only one working elbows on Monday cause you see how
effective it is and you're like,
okay,
I need to add that to my arsenal.
Remember when the front kick to the face started,
everybody started front cover has to face after.
For Anderson it was pretty rare.
Super Rich.
And then he knocks out,
beat doorbell for within.
And then we see Leono do it to [inaudible] town is proud knocks out,
we'll track down landed for analysis or announcers like,
well what should I do here?
And Pam knocked him out again and that was ridiculous.
Anyways.
Uh Yeah,
so see it's a copycat league.
So we'll kick wheel kicks everything.
Everything man,
relax.
We're good
man.
That's a tough thing.
Of course he regrets regrets it.
Yeah.
Don't let the guy ripped his shoulder.
That was probably had no idea that that was going to happen.
It didn't think about that.
But what was interesting about this fight when you guys were calling it,
and I'm not taking shots here,
but while you guys call it Goldberg use every second was chuck Ladell.
I'd love to see what chocolate l is saying here.
Chuck Ladell.
And he said,
I wonder if chocolate Dell,
how he feels about this fight right now.
Chocolate l thinks he chocolate El Co signed on chocolate out.
I was like,
dammit,
chocolate hell's not fighting right now.
Did he really say a lot of that?
He said a lot of chuck Liddell's.
Did I say any sharks?
I don't think you did.
I'm proud of you.
Okay,
thank you.
I'm proud of you,
man.
Well,
Goldberg,
you know like he has notes.
Yeah,
maybe that's it.
Listen,
talk about it.
Will.
We'll listen.
Trucks when you know one of the most famous fighters of all time,
people that don't know anything about Gloria.
That was like an important point I guess to talk about though.
Well,
it's the folks who didn't know anything.
I agree.
You're associating Chuck Ladell with Grover.
Grover is like the new age.
Chuck Ladell I guess.
And then when he picks them apart and John's,
John's done.
Great.
I'm proud of John for this because he's done great answering his critics.
If you've seen some of his Instagram posts,
their classic like Phil Davis talking all that smack.
Let's talk about Phil for a second.
Yeah,
so Dana White says to fill.
If for those of the listeners that don't know,
and probably Brian as well,
Phil Davis wants a title shot and Dana comes out like,
Bro,
you just don't seem like you want for call anyone out.
You're your,
you know,
these rankings,
these bullshit rankings,
these rankings.
You,
you got to make your way.
You got to show me you want it.
So Phil's not the best shit talker in the world.
And he starts doing it.
He did
it so much like when they had the press conference,
he was talking shit to John,
not even acknowledge any Anthony Rumble Johnson.
So he's taken a page out of Dana's book trying to get this big title fight.
He goes out and if you watch the fights,
gets Molly wiped by Anthony Johnson.
Not even a fight,
not even a fight.
And now,
I mean,
the criticism he's getting is ridiculous,
but big risk,
big reward.
You know,
what can you do?
So John Jones puts a video up of him watching Phil Davis fine stem or just
throwing idea.
Oh,
that's so funny.
It was classic.
That's
uh,
no,
I get what Phil's trying to do though,
man.
Let's say he goes out,
let's say he goes out and dominates.
Anthony Johnson gets a quick knockout.
He has a chance that they put them in next in line.
Yaffee dominant.
Anthony Johnson.
But Anthony Johnson is fucking scary.
Fight for a guy at two oh five is scary.
One 85 one 70 not that scary.
He plead himself too much.
He's a poster boy for the point of diminishing returns.
When you deplete yourself so much,
you have no energy left.
But I say this all the time.
How does someone not say,
hey Anthony,
you're 240 pounds.
You think fight at once.
70 smart,
bro.
Come on man.
You can answer that yourself.
How many times have you told,
you said on this podcast,
I wish someone would've
talk to us.
Doesn't happen.
When you asked,
when you asked her for for big Nog in Brazil,
I think it's like your third fight.
Wanted to give me that fight in Denver.
I said,
no,
let's do it in Brazil.
How about that?
Oh my God,
great.
Great decision maker.
Should sit shop down.
You understand jet lag,
you know that work.
Do you know about flying in planes?
Fuck that noise.
It's like taking seven x rays.
Not good man.
Knock a couple of days before you fight or flight.
It's a long flight.
Hang out in the stadium for like 10 hours.
Can real here's the fight.
Oh No,
this is his Instagram video.
Anthony Classic blinking.
But the thing is Phil deserves it.
I love Phil.
Well the first one of my favorite people in the business I love fill to just try
and play the game.
He's trying to get people to know I'm not,
I love Phil.
I think that what he's trying to do is get people to pay attention.
You know and it's,
it's sometimes it backfires.
That was a tough fight.
He should have been,
I think that bad matchup.
They also look for you to fail when you start doing something like that.
So if you're doing it before even one,
you're fine.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's a point of return on,
on getting,
it will be less than it would be if you started talking shit after you won.
Like if you're talking shit about getting another fight when you have a fight
coming up against the guy,
cause he's the favorite against you guys are fucking dangerous guy with a lot of
people.
I don't know what the actual fake Johnson was.
The underdog.
I'm not to me,
I didn't know what the hell's going on.
Anthony hits too hard,
but the top 15
from one to 1515 Camille,
horrible matchup for number one.
It's a mound styles and spout matchups so Phil Davis,
there cannot be a worse match up from the Nancy Johnson Johnson.
Leo Machida.
What are we talking about?
Some don't think he wanted to.
He won that fight.
It's close though.
He didn't get dominated like he did against Anthony Johnson.
You're absolutely right.
It was a big difference between the images of the bigger underdog.
Yeah.
The Machita fight,
he was,
it was close wide.
That was a close fight.
I just thought,
what do you think it was about?
Was just rumble just to is a monster.
It's just too much of a monster.
Monster.
Rumble's a scary guy.
Yeah,
he's too big tops kid heavyweight.
God,
it's so crazy.
I almost stopped him in the first round.
I broke his John Half and the first round like ours.
I'll ask you fought the last two rounds with the John.
That was shifting up and down cause it was shattered in the side.
Somebody is fighting our last game.
I'm just got some good stories.
When we talk about how guys are hyping fights,
it came back fine like with the metro and fight.
Me and Matt,
uh,
you know we're buddies where we can both talk a little smack.
So it was good to hype the fight talking smack.
It was great.
When you fight legends like Mirko Cro,
cop,
Andrea Lawsky,
big Nog with our Lawsky fans or hit me up on Twitter like,
oh,
I can't wait to see what your smack talk is.
There's no smack talk.
I don't need to talk smack to Andre Arlovski to hype this fight.
He's a legend.
You're not going to win any fans over.
What are you going to say?
Oh man,
he fought the very best fighters in the world.
You're a heavyweight champ.
You know what I mean?
What are you going to do?
You gotta be super respectful,
man.
Otherwise they fucking attack like,
well,
the fight sells itself.
But tell him,
tell his story about how,
how you wrote your a training with our Lasky after training where he's,
he goes,
come here.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
Andrea Alaska and I used to train together Jackson's camp and when I was getting
ready for a fight this over shoot almost four years ago,
the two fighters that I,
when I first got into the game that I admired and loved where Mirko Cro cop and
Andrea [inaudible] by two very favorites.
That's who I wanted to be like.
So I walked in the gym and it was our last keys first day at Jackson's too.
And uh,
you know,
when you seen a guy on TV fighting all the time,
then you run into and be like,
damn,
all right.
So I see.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
there's Andre Arlovski.
So then I got shopper last year in the ring,
first day spine,
right,
fresh off the plane when I'm sparring with him.
So me and him are gone and it's,
it's a close round.
He's a bad ass right at here.
We're going back and forth.
People would literally stop and watch a spar.
We're just these dog rounds back and forth,
five rounds in a row there.
And then later that night we grapple.
And then,
uh,
the next morning I drink coffee every morning,
right.
Drinking coffee and out this horrible coffee breath,
breath smell like pure coffee,
shit breath.
Right.
And I'd go up to Andre and he's,
he's not very warm person at all.
Not at all.
Is that very bell reus rush and where it's going to take awhile to be his
friend.
I can tell and I'm trying to break these barriers fan.
I go,
hey bro,
I just want to let you know,
man.
I got the coffee breath and he uh,
he didn't say a word to me the night before training goes,
it's okay.
It's okay.
Much better than yesterday.
Yesterday.
Shit cool.
He goes yesterday,
breath smelled like shit.
Oh,
oh cool man.
Cool.
And then just went about our business.
That was really the only words he ever said to me,
man.
And we trained together for a while.
It wasn't even like,
what about when you were kicking,
when he had you kick his body?
Yeah.
And then we get done training.
I've never done this.
He goes,
I'm trying to do my best Russian accent it.
You guys are pretty much terrible Russian.
That's horrible.
Right?
Well sorry,
I'm not from Russia.
The bus,
he goes up,
he goes,
put your hands on top of your head like this.
And I'm like,
what are we doing?
And we just got done sparring.
I'm exhausted.
I put my hands up and he just goes braced herself and starts wailing at my body.
Why?
With kicks punches Waylon.
It was this,
this make you tough.
My okay.
And I'm like,
ah,
I'm trying to be tough though.
Cause he's my hair.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
Wow.
And then he goes,
my turn,
you do it to me and I'm like doing,
he goes,
no,
you hit like girl hit and I'm fucking trying man.
Trying to hurt this guy.
Nothing.
And that was my experience with Andrea [inaudible].
Oh no man.
And now you're got to fight him for years.
Now I've got to find him how I was a,
I was sitting on the beach and I get a call from Lex Mcmahon,
my mangoes,
burrow,
and whenever he calls me multiple times,
cause I rarely answer whenever we calls him multiple times,
you know,
you got to fight.
He calls me guy,
whatever,
ignore calls again,
ignoring.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
we got some answer.
I'm like,
what's up man?
He goes,
Amigo,
we got to fight.
Like,
yeah,
hunt,
hunt.
Finally fricking saddled up and sign the contract.
He goes,
nope,
we used to be your hair.
I'll go get the fuck outta here.
I knew right away I knew what they reassigned Andrea [inaudible].
Yep.
And I done.
He,
I was like done.
When is it?
He was seven weeks.
Cool.
Let's do it.
Vancouver June 14th,
UFC one 74 going down.
Don't,
don't,
don't Dan.
And she gets real,
left the beach straight to the gym.
So today we just decided,
slept like shit last night.
Brian is going to join me on those,
uh,
those dates so that he could be there with his boyfriend,
the kids,
my date in Vancouver and Lloydminster Bolt of those,
Brian Cowen and Tony Hinchcliffe is coming to session fun.
Oh,
by the way,
I'll be at the Calusa casino tomorrow and then I'll be,
where's that?
Edmonton and and Toronto this month.
I'm going to Ryan,
count.com.
Brian Cowen.
Yuck.
How many fighters in the kid you guys doing a week,
but just one.
Do one a week.
When are going to break free from the teat of big business?
Very soon.
We're killed it,
man.
What?
It's doing well over there.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Good pocket.
We're trying.
It's funny.
What'd you think about the rest of the card?
The rest of the EOC?
Ah,
I thought Joe a joy.
Benevidez like,
great.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I haven't seen a guy tap with his feet like that.
Dope.
Right.
All the years of the UFC.
I don't think there was another time where a guy tapped his feet like that from
a mouse.
A joke.
The joke constrict Joa constructing was tight.
It was nasty,
super tight,
full mount with both arms trapped inside and a gay teen.
Pretty wild.
It's pretty wild technique.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you who I came away probably besides John Jones off.
So you just destroyed Glover.
But the guy who looked the best to me it was Luke Rockhold.
Yeah,
the guys at diabetes to look real good.
He's a handsome dude.
Hansel bastard.
I got him over you and I apologize.
Hard to believe that it really weighs a buck 85 like when you stand tall,
right?
He's like such as call scrawny guy.
He's not like a thin one 85 you could see him eventually deciding that he
doesn't want to make that weight anymore and going up to two oh five cause I
don't know how old he is.
How old is he?
Is Less than 30 right?
31 zero fucking guys surface.
A surfer who just came to Aka Aka and was like,
let's do this.
That reverse triangle was dope.
I thought he was gonna go for the arm earlier though.
Yeah,
well nobody's doing his patient.
He didn't want to lose the position,
but he also was going to lose it though.
29 he did a really good job of making sure that,
uh,
he got that the side up,
got him on his side,
didn't let him flatten out.
Guys will try to flatten out and try to protect the Camorra and he made sure he
got him yanked up to a side that triangles nasty to triangles.
Nasty.
It's tough to finish from there.
You've really hard.
It's very tough.
It's very hard to finish with the triangle.
It's,
that's what I'm saying,
the triangle to finish that reverse drank like that's very tough.
Braulio he's rather steam was nasty with it.
Have you ever rode with him?
No,
I have not.
Got a very weird style.
That duck under style of attacking that inverted triangle.
He's got,
he,
you know,
he has an artificial disc in his neck.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a benefit.
It's look how dope trapped in arching his back.
It's like a guard from the mouth.
That guard.
A lot of guys are doing their guard like that in their mouth,
their mouth.
They're crossing their feet under lake guard.
Yeah,
but under the body and the actual body and if you have like a really good strong
tight guard and you do that from the mount boy you,
you fucking sat the will out of a guy because you take away a lot of breath.
You when you really clamped down on it.
I'm like that.
It's very hard for them to breathe in.
A lot of guys freak out when you get an amount that mount like that.
You look at Benevidez how much arc he's putting in there and how much torque.
That's an expert blackbelt mount.
He's a,
he's a beast and then you see other guys mounts where they're like kind of
sloppy,
very loose.
There's no pressure.
Benevidez is just crunching.
It's a perfect name.
The JOA constrictor.
It's a perfect game.
I love that.
He's a great guy too.
One of the best man.
He's cool.
He's funny.
He's a,
he's a good dude.
Yeah,
it was interesting watching that.
So we start good Jujitsu technique and then Jim Miller caught Yancey Madeiros
and that the creatine and put them to sleep and then was celebrating why was
underneath him first time ever guys on top of you unconscious and Miller was
solid skill ref get them off man.
Crazy.
Jim Miller's Jujitsu is ridiculous is you see him submit for BCO cowboys with an
arm bar,
high levels.
Highballs slipped it in there like a glove.
And he was like,
what?
I can't believe this.
You could see like when the arm bar was locked up,
it'll look in,
come on his face like he's a Hoya Gracie black belt.
She's like,
I can't believe I'm getting submitted by an American.
Oh you motherfucker.
[inaudible] Silva.
John Silva knocked out,
uh,
Eric Silver.
You're talking to mark silver.
But if you ever see don young him knock him out.
Yes,
Don Young Kid,
man.
You know Kim is a beast.
Yes he is,
but he's still young.
He comes out of black house,
but it seems like he's got all the talent in the world and he's just,
he,
you know,
cause he rushed.
I think he just got who,
Eric.
No,
he didn't know.
He's just,
he's been tested by Fitch.
Fitch beat him in a decision.
He's been in there with some really good guys.
He's got a lot of potential and he's definitely getting better.
But there's no,
every week everyone's a black belt in that.
Like I say at 1505170140 five you're basically a blackbelt.
Everything,
every lacking,
anything else you're going to get.
So competitive.
The top 20 you're going to expose Elvis.
Elvis is back,
came out,
guns blazing,
took two years off,
looked like he never missed a step leg kicks with.
Oh,
it's beautiful technique.
I held a pad for Taga when he was kicking.
Show me how to,
how to kick and I held a pad and he just kind of laid in with some kicks,
like some low kicks to the legs.
I was shocked.
It was shocking.
It was shocking how strong his leg,
his big,
strong as all that good.
But it's great.
But his technique is what's so beautiful.
He throws that straight,
right?
Right leg kick and that left hook,
right leg kick.
And it's fucking devastating.
His timing is so perfect.
He rarely gets checked.
If you watch like the amount of guys that get the legs kicked checked versus the
amount of times that guys land them.
There's some guys that are just uncanny at landing them and not getting checked.
Tiago is one of the best.
Although all those,
all those fantastic,
you'd be the best.
Barao was fantastic.
Round Morales mass guys.
Brown can fuck you up with anything so you can fuck you up with a long punch.
Fuck you up in the background.
It did.
He book people don't realize Borow is our Floyd Mayweather.
The guy hasn't lost him forever but he does have one loss.
He does Floyd Mayweather.
Floyd Mayweather is undefeated.
Stay in MMA though but in MMA to have one loss at a pretty impressive
background.
No,
I know,
but what does his background as far as like,
cause he's a novel and young guy.
He's a Jujitsu black belt who got into a MMA posing tie.
His jujitsu's worldclass is his fucking striking is fantastic.
Writing is so good.
That's like,
it's the same.
He trains at all though.
So,
I mean it's,
it helps to have a fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
it's kind of like quite soon.
Training partner is,
is a Cain Velasquez as you know.
It's fine.
Tj Dillashaw,
Tj Dillashaw and him are fighting in May very well.
Do you think of that fight?
Tj Dillashaw is a tough kid.
He's a really good athlete.
He's a,
a really good fighter.
Is a big step up at giant step up.
I mean,
I think he's improved without a doubt.
Over the last couple of rounds we're going to have some fun.
It's a lot to chew off.
Browse.
No joke.
He might be the best.
It's like there's,
there's three guys,
four guys that are contention for being the best.
And number one is John Jones in my opinion,
the way he shuts guys down.
Everybody except Gustafson Gustafson fight was,
I think Gustafson's fucking fantastic.
I think,
you know,
I don't think there's any,
any slight on John because the gossips and fight was close.
I think it's just,
cause gossips is not good.
But if you see what he did to glow over,
see what he did to rampage.
You see what he did to Machida.
Who else does Dominic?
Who else get,
I mean he caught also caught by an arm bar and the veto or fight,
let his arm hyperextended his still won the fight he got his arm is bent and his
whole body,
I mean that was the craziest arm bar I've ever,
I mean,
it was nasty.
It was a nasty,
beautiful,
perfect.
Armbar and John's still didn't tap.
A lot of guys would have tapped.
A lot of guys would have tapped his arm was pretty fuck for a long time.
I plus it makes sense.
Fucked up his toe when he fought Chell son in snap that bench and rolled it
over.
Yeah.
I mean if he didn't stop channel in that first round,
that fight was over.
His toe is useless.
Bone was sticking out.
It was twist around a circle.
It was all dislocated and turned the wrong way.
It was fucked up,
man.
He's John's the beast.
He's an animal.
The best we all do.
It's all going to go up to 55 I think he's going to have to,
I honestly think that that holds Aldo back.
I think it's like a rumble Johnson type way.
Yeah,
I think it's a rumble Johnson type thing and we were talking about that.
What else is with formats 45 though?
Well there's a lot of guys,
Cub Swanson for one,
he's got the title though.
That's the big thing.
It doesn't matter.
He beat cop with one knee,
one flying knee back in the WEC days and cubs saved east cubs.
The most tactic I've ever seen in the training room.
I think carbon cub is a real threat.
I think customer never seen anything like it.
Real literally a real life Ninja really.
He was sparring and I was just like,
it's rare.
I stopped and watch guys and amazed and I was watching them.
It's like Dang.
Just cause his ability to come in and out.
He's kind of an awesome cavity.
The creativity you had was like nothing I've ever seen.
Wow.
And he hasn't even unleashed all of it yet.
He's still not to that level.
Wait till he unleashes it.
However,
although I think there's bigger matchups at 55 I think you're right.
And I think that he would probably be better served physically at 55 I think
it's really hard for him to make that weight.
So like you see the Aldo Aldo will come out guns blazing and the first few
rounds,
but then he realizes he's not going to get a guy out of there if he thinks he
might not be able to get a guy out of there,
it's just going to beat him up.
Well,
you know,
he'll start to pay the coast,
you know?
And I think the reason why he does that most likely is because the fact that
he's cutting down from a lot of weight and he's probably walking around over one
seven and he's getting down to one 45 it's crazy.
And he's a lean guy,
you know?
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know.
Is that exact walking around weight?
I would ask him how tall I was pretty fat.
No,
it was very,
very,
very muscular.
But he's so God damn good.
His left hook right leg.
So good,
smoothest and quickest.
And who does he have the most trouble with in 55 Serone or no,
no,
I mean he's got some great fights.
Who knows who,
who's going to have a hard time with it at 55 55 would be amazing to find that
55 he still has a possible rematch,
a Chad Mendez at 45 that can be,
that's going to be interesting for.
Although though it's like why do that?
What's it do for you?
Money.
That's it.
I agree.
All right,
so then you going to go super fights.
You want make real money,
you'll see 55 yeah,
55 and pedis was [inaudible] was supposed to,
yeah,
I was supposed to happen.
Right.
But pennys has had some injuries.
He's had some injuries.
I mean these guys get banged up.
Pet is just had knee surgery,
so that's going to be a while before he gets there.
I'll tell you what,
uh,
is going to be huge for the UFC and just for heavyweights in general is Cain
Velasquez versus Fabrizio for doom in Mexico.
Sosh that's going to be Mexico.
Otherwise for Risa,
resume speaks perfect Spanish.
Perfect.
Literally the UFC,
it couldn't be more perfect.
Came versus the reseal.
Reseal speaks better Spanish then Cain.
Yeah.
So they're fighting in Mexico and they have these two as the tough coaches.
I mean literally picture perfect for the UFC.
Yeah.
And Dude,
how,
how good it Fabrizio duck look against travelers praising.
That was amazing.
His,
his Double Jab,
double jabs,
triple,
just so inspiring.
And so he looked at her and punching and looking the other way and matching kick
for Kik and kept up to his feet and then kicked him in the body back trying to
get them to come to his guards and like just like matrix.
He kept stopping and throw the body France,
just cotton by the way to come back after all that time and be that confident
and it'd be looking like you're having fun and just,
you know,
having to go through a fucking dangerous moment in that first round at first run
was super dangerous.
Trash bag might be.
Yeah,
one of the most dangerous.
Was he talking to him?
Joe,
you were there.
Was he talking to him?
He was taunting him.
What was he saying?
Telling him you're cut.
Cut,
cut.
Cut this open.
Yeah.
They pop them again with a jab.
Really telling them to do was cut and he's kicking his legs and kicking his body
wasn't kicking his legs too much.
Actually I can think of,
I think a lot of smart,
he sang about uh,
Yoel Romero.
It looks so amazing.
He's a freak man.
He's a phrasing other one.
That's a real challenge.
At one 85 I got to be Kale Sanderson twice.
Yeah.
You know,
he's incredible.
Yeah.
And he's a world champion.
Weight throws dudes around.
It's just so he started using his wrestling finally.
Yeah.
Boy He was in Cuba and Europe and stuff.
The reason that like international rest is a lot of times beat Americans,
Americans or freestyle collegiate wrestling.
And in Europe they start more from the clench.
They do a lot of Greco,
so they're clinches way back.
So when you fight it internationally like that,
when you wrestle internationally,
it's very different.
So you tie it with a guy like Yoel Romero.
Good luck dealing with that Greco dude.
Good luck dealing with those throws,
but it's not just that.
The other thing about that guy is his striking.
He hits and he's so fast.
He has been striking.
How long?
I mean that's a nice,
please see him and Hector lumbar fight each other.
They train together,
they trained their different weaknesses.
You all's been fighting 85 in Lombard is way better at once.
Just cut it at 70 yes.
Yeah,
I like him look great below lumbar dude.
His judo is ridiculous.
Those fucking throws it.
He had Jake shields,
nobody have a rag dolls.
Jake shields like that.
I ever Netflix a pro.
You'd never see that.
That's just what a freak.
Yo that Hector lumbar.
Yes they all were married was a free clinic.
And what real y'all with?
Well Brad to vars.
Is it legit?
You know Brad tomorrow.
It's a very tough kid.
Is it dangerous striker and you know the Derek Brunson fight?
Derek Brunson head kicked you over American down twice but he had kicked him
like picture perfect.
Well,
like it was like it was a piece of toast with butter on it,
which is still bouncing around like nothing had happened.
He looks like a superhero.
Like his body's so written moves like the,
when he covers distance here.
Like what the fuck is nine Paul?
36 yeah.
Yeah.
He's not young.
I believe he's 36 he's a slowed down at all.
It doesn't look 37 actually.
It doesn't look like it means anything.
I bet you it does though.
I bet.
I bet you it does.
I bet you in the right you mean or I bet recovery.
I bet he can't train as long.
I bet.
I bet to him.
Look at that.
Good Lord Jesus Christ.
Can you go over here?
I'll Tiago Alvarez,
bro.
That is Tro Romeo back in the day.
That looks like Tiago.
It looks like he's got a belt on too.
Like swearing,
like work shorts.
I mean he's wearing or May to war it say,
well,
he's got a weird look on his face.
Look,
he looks like Tiago doesn't any does.
He does.
Let's find another picture of him.
We actually see what he looks like,
but he's that redundant,
elite athletic guy like that at 36 and I've talking to some other guys who were
a little old on Jesus Christ.
Good Lord.
He looks,
he looks that he's more muscular than the wolverine in the cartoons and the
cartoons,
but he looks like a cartoon that barely,
it looks like a real guy.
But for guys at 36 and have that background,
and I'm sure there's injuries we don't know about.
There's a,
there's a timing sensitivity with him.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they're not gonna lose two in a row and be like,
well,
got to get back on the horse.
Let's do this.
Right on,
man.
He's going there.
He wants to get those big fights.
Oh,
no doubt.
And not only that,
like stylistically think about matching him up with Chris Weidman.
I mean,
why would it turn up for a striking and Weidman's known for his wrestling?
I think he went on for Polk,
but who wants to wrestle that kind of nobody who wants to strike with the back?
Well,
I'll tell you what's tough.
I have.
I think this is where Weidman's Gabby advantage.
If Weidman mixes up and dragged them into later rounds,
maybe,
I don't know.
That's what I'm saying.
That's your only hope.
Only hope.
We don't know.
He controls fighter.
He controls fight so well that you,
you know what people say that he gets tired.
But the thing is he's just so relaxed in there and when he really takes
advantage of anybody move in a certain way,
well he explode so much.
And any of those guys that explode that much,
those guys get tired quicker than a guy like Nick Diaz who just keeps going at
the same pace.
Those guys were up and being worn out in the middle of the octagon against scary
guy is a terrifying place to be.
So everybody keeps pushing.
He's tired.
He can target getting tired.
Like that's what,
when,
when he was fighting this past weekend,
Brad to Vars,
his corner,
Ray Sefo was telling them that it's you guys tired.
He's tired,
he's tired,
he's tired.
He wasn't really wasn't that tired.
They didn't look that tired.
But that's what she gonna say.
You're the corner.
So you got,
you got to bake,
you gotta Bank on that.
You got to say,
you got to knock this mother fucker out,
void him at all costs and then sneak attack.
We Cook Ramzi Shit.
But the reality of the situation is not good.
Okay,
let's throw out the window.
Any good.
That's why I couldn't be a code option.
Damn son.
This fool's gold with the pope.
We get offensive mode.
This is what we're going to do.
Full defensive mode and then occasionally sniper attack and then the runaway.
But other than that,
I want you running,
always running,
running.
We have more fight in us.
Let them disqualify you.
Want them to forget about Caleb Starnes I don't even want them to remember Caleb
Starnes after your performance tonight.
Stay alive.
Son is always the world series of fighting move.
Given your fucking meals,
do you ever heard of [inaudible]?
They're interested in you.
Run
wants you to be their champion one.
That's the reality of,
of the business,
right?
I mean,
when you're
physically that way and you're,
it's the second round and you're out of options for this guy.
No,
you guys,
it's championship aspirations.
But if you're a regular guy that has no shot,
if you one of those mid level guys that has no shot ever,
there's a certain point in time someone has to pull you aside and go,
you're still a postman.
You always have to.
You're not going to be Yoel Romero.
You're not going to be w two time world champion.
You're not going to remember.
It's so fucked up.
He goes back to the corner,
Yo son,
reality check.
Listen,
this guy is so much better.
I think what we should do is pro,
you know I'm gonna call belt or as soon as we get to allow st just what you want
you to do,
you're gotta make up a story about being injured and then you get a run just run
and while you're running and want you to think about what you're going to say
afterwards and they post fight interview,
that's gonna make people forgive you for running.
Entertaining does slip and just hit your head and faint.
Obviously we're joking.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't get upset and don't quote this for any fucking look at that.
Boom.
Oh God,
that's ridiculous.
He's a beast dude.
He's a beast and that this is just a striking look at that right hand that's
just as striking his wrestling,
the way he ragdolled Tavarez there was even more impressive.
His wrestling is ridiculous and is the first fight that he used it.
And that's what I'm saying,
we haven't really seen his wrestling cause when he goes to the gym it's all
striking cause he's done wrestling so much.
It's second nature.
It's like Rhonda,
she's not doing a ton of judo.
He's easy.
He's going with a high level judoka like uh,
um,
Bar Lombard,
Tyron Woodley,
he's down there too.
There's a lot of really fucking strong guys.
Look how fucking fast he's,
that's the 37 year.
Beautiful Fuck to plank down.
Oh my God.
That Greco stuff.
He's going to get a big,
tough fight next I give you that elbow pulling.
God is going to get a big name.
That dude,
he's easy to sell.
He's a goddamn silver medalists and one of the most decorated wrestlers and a
nice guy.
Nice guy.
Nobody's ever beaten cal like that twice.
He's a beast and he's just a,
he's interesting too cause he's super relaxed when he fights too.
It's relaxed,
calm,
calm bloke.
He's just,
he's been involved in high level competition for so long that he just knows the
proper mindset for winning.
So Corey [inaudible] has two amazing same,
yeah,
Columbia has that same thing man.
I feel bad about myself when you see core me right now.
Just watching your a marrow.
I feel bad about myself.
You'd be coming.
Even Mcclellan already established this.
You slowly I'm getting all my face is more narrow.
My nose is getting bigger.
I used to be cute.
Next podcast is going to show up with a scarf on.
What are you doing?
You know,
I want to be that guy.
I love the theater.
I want to just reminds me of a theater,
a tweed jacket and you'll be like a small English accent.
You will be.
I guess Brian have like,
I'd be like,
I'm having a wonderful time with you guys.
I have to say,
it'd be really subtle.
It would be like,
I must tell you the fighter and the kid podcast and be like,
what's going on when his voice cause real subtle.
It's just an extraordinarily good summer in Cape Cod now.
We had a wonderful time.
They'll go from the current Cowen acts into like,
it's just weird,
neutral sound and then it would slowly morph as time went on.
You know,
I lend my sentences with Henry Miller once said,
is that state that Stevia?
Yes.
Is that coffee yet?
It comes from a plant.
It's an extract.
Of course.
I'll tell you what,
I spend a great deal of time in the Amazon.
Great people,
wonderful people down that way.
What makes,
what makes or breaks flights for me,
like the Verdugo fight.
Uh,
most fights,
it depends who I watch it with.
I don't know.
We'll see.
You're always freaking on him.
Too busy,
but also love to watch fights.
Are you guys,
well,
what about in Brazil and stuff?
What would be the ones that I don't do?
I would love to wash it.
We should be doing that for a while.
While we would watch it,
we could set it up in here too.
By the way.
We get podcasts while we're watching the fights.
Right.
It's brilliant.
We can totally do that.
It's like you know what you're doing.
When is the next one?
Really it,
um,
in Brazil.
Uh,
where's Eric?
So,
but wasn't,
that doesn't have to be Brazil.
When is the next fight?
Dude is probably a fight that we could podcast from this room while the fight is
going on.
Just do it on Ustream and just let everybody know it.
Listen,
this is not a regular podcast.
Okay?
If you're expecting cohesive,
cohesive content,
something to make sense all over.
Turn this off right now because what we're doing is we're watching fights.
So if you want a companion to watching the fights will sync with some educated
opinion,
but it'd be fun to do.
Oh Shit.
J D s versus me.
Oh,
chick.
Oh Shit.
That's way,
that's it.
No,
you got Munoz Musashi.
And what's before that?
That's the one that found Silva.
May 10th can we do it?
Can we do it boys?
Yes,
we can do.
We can do it.
That's a good goddamn fight too.
I'm here.
Let's do it.
Dot Brown.
Yeah.
Did I say Travis Brown?
Matt Brown.
Sorry.
Aaron and Matt Brown backgrounds coming off.
I'm sorry,
Matt.
Matt Brown is coming off of a back surgery to yeah,
not back surgery.
Excuse me.
A back injury.
He had a disc that herniated on him and he had a hard time,
uh,
in the middle of camp,
hurt his back and it had a pull out into watch Eric
of it might be a little better looking than big brown.
I'm going to be honest with Ya.
Fuck.
Sorry.
I see me in this tank.
You're a cute guy,
but he's a cutie pie.
He's got that hair in his highest,
almost.
No.
Matt Brown is a fucking animal.
A small to breaks cars off pieces.
What sets it guys just get your,
what's your calling that fight?
There's no car.
I never make a call,
but he's ferocious.
Brown is for fucking ferocious.
It's not just this pace,
it's his mind.
The fucking dude overcomes overcomes guys.
I don't think he's the most athletic,
but it's just his pace and demeanor.
Beats guys,
high level guy.
You got him over a tents.
I'm like Joe,
I never make pigs.
Yeah,
not good to meet stops.
Doesn't make any sense.
Tough.
However,
however,
the reason why we should definitely let fights together is for me,
it's tough to watch fights.
It's super tough to,
well it depends.
It will literally ruin a fight for me because I been with him.
Where were we're dudes,
bro.
Like Rhonda is a very close friend of mine.
It's different when you watch finders,
you know,
fight,
right.
I'm trying to order the paper view and the,
the,
the main cards about to start my fucking cable will work.
Right?
So I'm freaking out.
I'm like,
what am I sweating?
I'm not going to go to a bar.
Not Chance.
I'm showing up to a bar watching the UFC fight cause you just get harassed.
Get mobbed.
So I'm like,
what am I gonna do?
So I texted my coach Tony,
who lives in Santa Monica.
I'm like,
Bro,
I need you to get the fights.
He's like,
Bro,
I'm over this guy's house.
I know you hate watching with other people.
Everyone knows this about me because I know you hate watching other people.
No one's really here,
man,
come to the basement.
This guy,
they probably won't know who you are.
Just come like fuck you.
It's only thing to do.
I race down there,
I make it just in time.
There's like two guys there,
but they're pretty drunk and I come in with a hood,
you know that he can't really tell.
So I just sit down.
All of a sudden these dudes a shine to pack in.
You've heard this story by and these guys are packing in,
right?
And I'm like,
Dang,
I'm getting,
I just get uncomfortable because I'm like,
man.
Then you start asking me questions,
Blah Blah Blah.
So finally one of the guys,
he was probably 50 years old,
highest shit,
which is whatever you,
I know you guys support that high shit.
Cheeto fingers.
CIDO fingers,
grateful dead tee shirt,
right?
I want to give a motivational talk,
but he looks over at me and just goes,
Oh shit,
Brendan Schaub Mike,
what's up man?
It was,
oh man,
blah.
And then so from there I'm taking pictures of guys watching a fight and it's my
nightmare.
I'm like,
oh no,
and this is why it's my nightmare.
During the middle of fight,
one of the guys go,
hey bro,
hey bro.
Do you know Max Holloway?
And then that Max Lawler,
he is some random name.
Do you know Max Billy?
Do you know Max Billy idol?
Uh,
how would I know him?
He was a,
he wrestled me in high school,
man.
Yeah.
How would I know you got to wrestle with in high school years?
I have all your answers,
man.
I'll you Russ or stick together Bro.
And that's the kind of Shit I'm dealing with during fights.
And then this is the best part.
Then Ron is walking out one guy,
they have no idea,
right?
Rhonda and I close.
He goes,
Bro stands up,
would you fucker?
Who would you fucking hell no man,
way too big one guy goes,
oh hell yeah.
I would tap them and I let her arm bar me and I'm literally sitting there like,
oh no.
Locking the door and beating,
slapping everybody with an open hand.
I wish I were spanking literally as soon as they use the Sara Mcmann fight,
she needs the girl and gets out of there.
I literally bolt out the door.
See Ya.
Thanks for the fights and startup along.
Got Mister.
It's tough man.
It's tough to watch fights.
Yeah.
You don't want to watch anything that you care about with morons cause they're
going to talk over it and they got,
all they do is talk the whole fight bro.
So what are you thinking?
Are you get nervous four or five?
Does it hurt?
Does it hurt when you get punched in the face at her when you get punched in the
face?
Listen,
if I'm home we'll do them right here man.
It's perfect.
We have two TVS here and other TV out there.
We're good.
It's exciting.
We can,
we could,
I usually prefer to watch them by myself in the dark.
Watch him jacking off with my tears.
I watch them almost always jack knife,
my tears cause I'm not fighting.
Just Ooh crap.
I'll watch him with Brian and he'll be like,
bro,
my friend,
but expert bro Expert at this.
Brian does,
man.
He's my friend's an expert.
Oh really?
He's picking the six to one favorite to win.
Oh Wow.
Genius.
He's good though.
See friends that are experts.
Brian,
buddy gays.
Casey's both our friends actually.
He's a good fighter.
He's tough guy.
Brandon just shook his head.
Well.
I mean he knows it.
He knows what he's talking about though.
He wrestled with and fan fight.
There's a lot of arms going on there.
I don't feel a confidence.
Brian throws with the word the word fight around a lot.
Pretty uncanny.
How good.
How do you get,
do you think he is?
Well,
I mean as her pitch John Jones to win has to be good.
He won nationals in Jujitsu training.
We asked,
Sylvia asked how good or his pics,
oh,
almost a hundred percent I disagree 100% because he's a wrestler.
So he support Sarah McMahon and Brian goes,
what do you,
what do you think of a sick man?
Miss Rhonda Rousey?
And I go make man very talented fighter.
It will be the easiest fight of her career.
I guarantee you it's true.
Because I see Ron does training.
I know Sara McMahon.
I see her right?
I see what she's done.
I'm telling you it's going to be your easiest fight.
And he argues,
oh,
it's going to be the hardest fire,
career,
whatever,
easiest fire around this career.
So that's whatever that may be.
However,
let's talk about this with Rhonda though.
The reason why these girls are fucked when they fight Ronda,
cause the same thing as the Mike Tyson effect.
These girls go from fighting on Facebook prelims.
They win one fight and then you go,
hey,
great job.
Rhonda does everyone to fight.
Here you go.
Main event primetime.
Hey,
who's phone's going off?
Not Mine.
What does that clock
well,
that world
with somebody,
some alarm,
no alarm on it.
Give me a stupid thing,
but I bet I will regardless.
His picks are way better than both of ours,
not mine.
That's where it's seven to six.
That's how weird it was.
A sign not to go off.
I don't even know how to set it anyway.
Definitely.
That's scary.
I could never watch fights with morons.
I've done it before.
It's brutal.
They asked too many questions and the disrespectful to,
he's a bitch.
He's scared.
He's a bitch.
Like,
oh well that same party guy,
he goes pro our bar all day,
all day.
They're against the cage clinch.
There's no fucking arm.
But what are you talking about?
Oh No,
you're in the wrong place.
Yeah,
you should've just left.
I would've left for sure.
I want to grab my friend and fucking cock slapped him to,
well,
he didn't know either though.
He didn't know either.
So it was the worst.
It's the worst.
But he's inviting idiots over his house.
How she's not know who's coming to,
I was at my friend and I roasted them on the fire of the kid that next morning
and they all heard it.
And then the next day I go to the gym and that,
you know,
they're just regular students that I go the gym.
I can tell him I'm like,
son of a bitch.
I want to be like,
Yo,
Cheetah fingers come here.
Cheeto fingers.
Come here.
Let me talk to you.
I'm going to give a pep talk.
You're 50 but down the Cheetos ditched the shirt.
Let's go for a jog.
Wow.
How rude.
But necessarily
necessary.
Some dudes need to be heard.
I think so.
They need to hear that shit.
They don't want to,
but they need it.
But most people just want a pep talk from a line.
Casell I'm giving it for free man.
Wow.
There was a girl I dated who was a really pretty girl.
Nice girl and a way.
Yeah,
I'm stopping right there.
I'm going to check out full of shit.
I don't believe a fucking word.
Know the story and her breath was,
I mean it smelled like like an open grave.
Like I've never craziest thing I've ever smelled.
That's a deal breaker by the way.
I remember we were at the elevator.
I have to pencil.
I was excited about dating her and I went and I went,
that's weird.
It's impossible that someone's mouth could smell like that's not possible.
So I go,
that's probably doing meth.
Uh,
well,
no,
or sundown.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you what happened,
right?
We're second.
Nope,
nope.
So she couldn't get it.
So anyway,
long story short,
we're in the elevator.
I'm like,
Eh.
Then we get the cab,
this is in New York.
And I go,
all right,
there's a situation here.
She'll eat.
I just want to get laid.
I'm young.
I'm like,
let's just,
she'll eat it.
It'll be fine.
I don't know what's going on.
Ah,
I'm not,
I'm not going to pay attention.
I'm not gonna pay attention.
You know,
he just like,
it can't be,
uh,
we get to her place.
We started making out,
and I,
I'm telling you,
it was beyond anything I've ever smelled.
Like,
oh,
look,
at the time,
I don't know what I did.
I was like,
let me get out of here.
You know,
I'm such a bitch that I actually,
I didn't want to be rude.
I think I kissed her a little more and I was like,
all right,
hold your breath,
father.
I got out of there.
I say to her friend,
I go,
listen,
I got to tell you,
your friend is is great.
She's got the worst breath.
And she goes,
we all talk about that.
How long have you known?
She goes,
oh my God,
I'll do college.
She could never get a day.
She could ever called him.
And I go,
well,
can you,
can you tell her you're her friend you are doing her whole life is ruined
because you can't cause it's embarrassing.
Tell her that her breath smells like an open grave.
You gotta tell her.
That's a tough talk to have with someone.
May,
it depends on your friends.
I've had a friend who's a,
a fighter.
I'm not gonna mention names,
who,
he's not very good things.
Haven't been going his way and yes we will.
We should do.
I said,
I think she get a job.
Wow,
that's,
but that's you.
That's me the friend.
Nah Man.
Keep playing grab ass and hopefully things work out for you.
Do you know how many to many people know how many people in an acting class for
years?
I sat there and gone,
the note should be quit.
Quit you.
It's never going to happen.
You gotta to go back to college.
Brian,
Brian and I were talking about this on the right here.
Do you believe like something like talent,
you're born with talent,
either happy or not,
or is it a clean slate and from experiences,
it's definitely not a clean slate.
100%.
The people that are more talented,
it almost everything,
whether it's comedy,
whether it's music,
whether it's fighting on it or you don't,
right?
Physical talent without a doubt.
It varies wildly.
Vary so wildly.
There's advantages that certain people have that are so undeniable
is this fucking thing.
Oh my God.
Oh,
it's killed us.
What is it?
Well,
the physical talent,
David Epstein's book,
uh,
that the,
the sports gene,
um,
he,
he makes that case.
He proves that it's amazing.
I feel like a bomb is going to go off.
I hope it's not.
It's supposed to be just a nice little clock.
How does it,
it gives you a 10 minute warning.
Is that what it was?
Did you read that book then?
It's like a minute to six now.
You made that.
Do you see?
You heard of that bucket,
the sports gene you told me about a thousand times,
but I have not read it,
but uh,
it's without a doubt.
True.
There's certain athletes that just have a huge advantage.
I mean,
I think some people are just naturally better at math,
for example.
Sorry.
Yes,
it's 100% true.
It's 100% sure.
There's certain people that have been more eloquent way of describing things.
That's fascinating.
There's certain people that are better storytellers,
better at reading and emotion,
and I don't know why.
I don't know if it's a learned skill.
I think certainly storytelling is a learned skill.
It depends on who you around when you growing up.
I think too,
and I think that if you're a guy who's been around a fun,
if your dad's boring as fuck and you're boring as fuck,
and then finally have 30 you meet a bunch of charismatic people who know how to
spin a yarn too late,
you're behind it.
You're so far behind the eight ball,
you're never going to figure out how to be interesting so you better get rich.
There's an evolutionary biologist,
probably the most famous named Steven pinker at a Harvard University.
I know he is.
He wrote a book called the blank slate,
which I'm reading now about that saying,
we're not a blank slate.
You can certainly learn a great deal as a human being.
This.
There's a great Pete,
we have a huge potential
to change our lives with what we learned,
but the fact of the matter is most of the size proves the fact that some people
will have a proclivity for,
you know,
chess over whatever it might.
But not only that,
there's some people that have a lot of the aspects of her life that were
completely beyond their control until they became an adult.
Like the childhood,
how they were raised,
raised them.
Who abused him,
who fuck them up,
who put them in a bad situation?
What kind of fears?
Yeah,
what that did to their brain chemistry.
It without a doubt,
the wiring of the way,
the very way they think with sports is different too.
Like I,
I've had,
uh,
you know,
I've given college major college team talk,
stuff like that and then a gym,
I won't say any names.
They go Brendon,
come talk with these guys to tell him,
man,
tell him a lot of the guys aren't hitting mitts or they're not,
they're not showing it for training,
they're not doing this,
not doing that.
And I told them,
I said all right,
I mean I'll talk to them.
You don't want me to talk to him cause I'm coming to sport.
I'm very cut throat.
Right.
Let me see.
I've seen it all man.
I said,
listen,
if someone has to give you a pep talk and tell you to show up every day and
train,
it's too late.
You don't have it.
Cause I know guys who like they literally have you don't give me Jim keys,
I will be in that bitch 24 seven they do not give me a gym key cause I will
overtrain like a motherfucker.
So with these guys not even showing up,
and I know other guys just like me who aren't in the UFC and you,
we can't even get you to come to practice.
You're not that passionate about it.
You're wasting your time.
So the pep talk from me to you is go get a job.
Yeah.
If you're not completely obsessed,
it's not something you should be into.
Not a chance in fighting.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be dabbling.
And if you have to get a pep talk from a a guy,
you know who you might,
whatever he look up to,
who's in the UFC where you want to be at and he inspires you to get your ass in
the gym.
It's too late.
I always use this analogy I said,
can imagine,
okay,
imagine that you're a guy who says,
you know what,
I'm just going to have a few fights.
I'm just going to,
you know,
I'll give it a shot.
I'll give it a go.
I'll have a half an adventure.
What if on the other side of that adventure is a guy like Mike Tyson who's
completely obsessed,
not only is GE genetically gifted,
not only is he freakishly fast for a heavyweight,
not only is he trained by a guy who's become as mentors,
one of the greatest minds,
the world of boxing has ever known.
Custom motto when it comes to psychology and the,
the,
the pumping up of a fighter and the changing the fighter's mentality.
Custom motto was a bad motherfucker.
He would tell guys things that they would be able to carry with them for the
rest of their lives.
Look at Tyson's career when he passed away.
Yeah.
Well even after he got rid of Kevin Rooney.
Who was the last bond to a custom model.
But customer would tell him shit like food,
you know,
fire is,
it can either be your friend or it could be your enemy.
You can either cook your food with it or if he can't control it,
it'll burn your house,
your whole house down.
Fears like fire.
And that fear,
if you can control it,
it would make you a better finer.
So you're,
you're saying Billy McKee,
who doesn't,
who's not doing this is going to get tore up cause you gotta stir.
Fuck,
I'm just going to get,
you could get hurt at Marvin fractured and Marvin frame four times the Afro and
Tyson came out,
guns blazing,
most horrific display of destruction.
I think I've ever seen the heavyweight division because it was never a matter of
whether or not Marvis was going to win.
It was a matter of how many seconds it was going to take before Tyson land to
the boom on them.
And as soon as he cornered him,
he just started mauling him.
And you know,
Marvin said a famous dad,
Joe Frazier was his dad,
but he was never a guy that was a monster.
He was never a guy.
That was a scale.
So you can run into a monster even if you're Marvis your monster.
Imagine if it's you forget about anybody else.
Imagine if it's a,
you look and I'm looking down.
Yeah,
he's terrified.
This was when Tyson was,
before we even fought for the title,
and this was one of the big fights that sort of cemented in everybody's idea
that he was the next coming because Marvis Frazier had had some good fights.
He looked pretty good.
He looked like a good boxer.
He was really well trained.
But Tyson was a deem and like,
look how calm and Lucy was as he paced around the,
it's ridiculous.
We've played this on the podcast no less than five times,
just cause it's not,
in my opinion,
it's like one of the most devastating heavyweight performances in the history of
the sport.
And a perfect example,
and it was on ABC,
I'd love to see Marvis Marv,
uh,
Frazier fight Tyson.
Mike Tyson went done the same thing to Joe for probably right to people say,
no,
you got to watch the Frazier foreman fight.
Frazier always had a problem with,
but look at Cim.
Lampi sexy bitch.
Look at them doing the damn thing.
Young.
Passionate about boxing.
Oh yeah.
He loves it.
It talks about a shit about MMA.
Unfortunately.
I think he's come around.
I think I heard an interview lately where I think he's being [inaudible] that
legendary nights that Gadi Gadi Ward.
He starts crying.
Oh Man.
It was,
it's hard not to tear.
Look man,
look at this and Joe Frazier,
he got to know that his son is going to get crushed.
He knew.
Yeah,
he kind of,
I mean probably not,
but you got to have an idea.
I mean he knows that his son's capable.
That's Kevin Rooney.
Yeah.
This is after custom monitory.
Double lookout.
Jacked Carry Jack Trice.
How would he have done in MMA?
The same with a smoke people.
He would have been terrifying if you taught him
everything else.
I disagree.
I think it's tough to say that.
It's tough to say that.
You're right.
He's a very undersized heavyweight.
You'd gotten picked it like John Jones would have picked him apart.
Heavyweight.
He could easily have been two oh five he only weighed about two 1880 probably
one 85 wow.
That's crazy to think.
You mean cause he would have had to deal with that with kicks and stuff when it
wrestling,
it's hard to say,
man,
like a lot of guys aren't.
They don't want to wrestle.
They don't want to do just do they hate grappling?
Yeah,
so even if you have pushed her up so she had so he could see the actual fight
itself.
It doesn't look right about there as good thing.
Here it goes.
He was so fast.
He was so unmanageable.
You couldn't,
that was the other thing you were talking about in the fight with John.
John's trying to find out,
look at this.
If they don't even get a close up on them fast enough to see the destruction as
it's gone down.
They started the camera's way in a pullout,
but they don't realize at Tyson just charged Zach at the beginning of the round.
You can't just start
the camera away.
My sparring partners that,
that,
that mimic magnificent in the years.
Here it is.
Oh Bang,
Bang,
Bang.
No,
honestly,
this is a terrible video by the way.
That's one of the worst copies of the youtube videos.
Whoever put that up,
take it down.
Get yourself head knocked him.
Listen,
when,
when you fight Mike Tyson,
when he fight Jon Jones,
when you fight these certain guys,
you get one shot at him and it's live with millions of people watching because
you cannot duplicate in the gym.
You get one real life shot.
That's why people have so many problems with these guys.
John Jones,
listen,
there's no one in your gym the size of John Jones doing these weird kicks and
throwing these weird angles and doing these shoulder locks against the cage.
You get one real life.
Go at it.
And by the time you figured out it's too late.
Yeah,
he's so curious why these guys are so damn good.
Mike Tyson to you're telling me he was training with Tyson.
I've seen and do that arm ranch they did on Glover.
I've seen Tyson do that.
Tyson did Caulfield check yourself.
I remember that.
Fires a lot of box do a little bit.
They just haven't done it the way John did.
Illegal way,
clamped his hands together and do it.
I mean he,
uh,
he's off to put some levers here.
Johnson fucking beast restaurant man.
He's got a really good grappling.
The way he manhandled guys inside the clench to ticks guy's down.
He's a beast.
I think that Alexander Dustin fight was the best thing ever to happen to John.
John was like,
alright,
I need to pick it up here.
And he has,
what do you mean by that though?
I think when you,
when you're going through fights,
like he was these title shots where he wasn't really getting tested.
He's destroying guys,
right?
I mean,
it's hard not to believe your own hype.
Believe me,
I was four,
no knocked out Mirko Cro cop,
and I thought I was fricking God's gift to the UFC.
And I was like,
all right,
I'll still training my ass off.
I literally didn't think I could lose.
It was like,
Eh,
whatever.
Just keep doing my thing.
Just going to keep knocking everybody out.
It's whatever I feel like John,
man,
I just slid into that a little bit where you're like,
Bro,
this is dope.
I'll just destroying everyone.
And then you get a guy like Alexander who's just as big,
just as long.
I think John was like,
I need to step my game up here.
And he just absolutely dismantled clover to chair and that's why maybe it could
be also a stylistic thing to Gustafson as part of it.
That's part of it for sure.
Like you said,
John Jones didn't perform like he used to at one seven two man,
I couldn't agree with that.
Well,
Alexander's just trying to stay right.
He's trying to hype this fight.
You got to do it anyway.
He gets the next fight for sure,
but he's been talking to all sorts of smack.
Yeah.
Well,
of course he's saying he's saying John.
John doesn't want to fight me,
judge.
I was scared of me.
What else are you going to do?
What he's gotta say all that.
That's how you hype things up.
What are you going to do?
It's an interesting fight,
man.
I'll tell you that after the first fight.
It's an interesting fight.
I think you're going to see a way better John Jones in this fight,
but I think you're gonna see a better Gustafson too,
I think.
I think it won't be as close as well.
No,
I think one of them,
I don't think he's to me as close one.
I'm going to pull it.
I,
I'm not gonna make it pick,
but I think one's going to pull away,
man.
I don't know.
It could be,
I'll tell you what.
For BC over dooms a tougher matchup for a cane.
Then Travis Browne,
it's all about matchups.
I think verb ECO poses a lot of threats that cane,
you don't realize how big for BCO is.
He's big.
Travis Browne wasn't it that much bigger than him?
Not that much taller now for Breeshia was light for that fight too.
He's a little,
he's losing weight.
You got done at two 30 that's what guys are doing.
Like in Travis Brown came in at what,
two 30 cardio.
Kate.
It's a copycat league.
So Kayla destroying cats and then everyone's like,
oh,
that's cool.
I'm 260 pounds.
I can't make it that long.
I can't keep that pace.
All of a sudden,
everyone's getting lighter canes.
Cardios very unusual physically too.
He's got very unusual cardio just from genetics.
He's gifted.
Yes.
He's not your most explosive athlete,
but in as far as stamina goes,
he's a tendency say,
puts his head in your chest and just,
he's just so good.
You know?
He's just such a good fucking athlete.
I mean his,
his,
his stamina is incredible and it's technique.
Everything throws.
He doesn't have any wasted motion.
He never see him like pint in his teeth down,
throwing wild haymakers everything is strong.
Pricing's good.
Perfect technique.
Right.
Brendan,
why do you think of his boxing or what's the most impressive part of his game
besides his cardio for you?
I've seen for me,
I'll see by his box in his wrestling is amazing stuff like that.
What's amazing to me is he's,
he never lets the moment get to him.
I was talking about this,
Brian was asking about the Andrea Alaska,
you fight and I said this and now that I'm getting a little more experience,
you know,
this'll be my 10th or 11th fight in the UFC,
which is a lot.
And uh,
it,
it's not letting the moment get to you.
You don't,
you don't let the moment gets so big where you get freaked out.
And that happened to me in Brazil when I bought Nogueira.
It's the first time ever,
I was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Freaked out when they're throwing these crazy up guts.
I don't even throw uppercuts.
I'll throw in leg kicks.
That's not my thing.
I'm don't like kicks upper cuts.
Literally I watched that film.
Like,
who the fuck is that guy?
The moment got to me where I was like,
Dang,
this is a big moment.
I beat this guy.
Probably going to fight Brock Lesnar neck.
That's what I was told.
Probably gonna Fight Brock Lesnar neck.
So I'm,
I'm thinking of all these crazy situations.
That's when the moment get to you.
So with Andrea [inaudible] and for with,
you asked what's so impressive about Cain Velasquez?
Dude,
never have you seen that guy freak out.
Never have you seen them like,
oh,
what am I going to do and start fighting on unlike himself,
he sticks to a game plan and mentally he's just so solid.
That's the difference.
Right?
Like he said against you and Jill Santos is let this last fight and the third
round he goes,
man,
I was tired.
I was exhausted.
But I knew if I kept pushing he couldn't match his pace.
Well that's a championship mindset.
A lot of the guys.
Yeah,
I'm going to close it out here and he did it.
I like what Winkeljohn said that John Jones go out there and have fun.
Yeah,
they kept saying that that's what it's about.
He kept saying that and just have fun.
Well,
he's at his best when he's creative and you know,
and he,
he knows he's putting on a show and when he's putting on a show with a guy like
Glover,
part of the way that it put on a show was do shit that nobody saw coming when he
put his hands down.
Roy Jones style.
What?
How about when he got up against the cage?
Just was Roland with shot that it was phrased pawn blasted him with elbows and
punches as well.
I mean it was just stellar performance.
Picked him apart and just show that he's still getting better too.
Like that was the best he's ever looked.
It's getting better.
I agree.
Plus he was throwing shit like wheel kicks and stuff that you never saw common,
you know,
like Jesus Christ,
it's spinning back kick is outstanding now.
Crazy.
He's,
he's got a really good spinning back kick that,
you know.
Damn.
So there's so many,
so many,
a really,
really high level matchups these days and so many fighters getting better every
time you see him.
It's just you have to,
yeah,
you have to,
you have no choice.
So that this goes back to that.
So if you're not passionate about the sport,
especially mixed martial arts,
but in life in general,
if you're not passionate,
Solon is,
you know what I'm saying?
So you cannot keep up,
especially in pro sports.
What did you think about,
what did you think about Edson Barboza Donald's Serone what you think about
that?
That was crazy.
Yeah.
Is My boy.
Right?
And I always tell Brian this,
when cowboy walks out from the time,
I can usually tell if he's going to win or not.
If cowboys mentally ready,
he's the best one 55 in the world.
To me,
I'll say I'm a little bias.
I think he's one of the very best in the world when Donald,
let's the moment get to him.
Donald doesn't fight like Donald,
uh,
the dos Anjos fight.
That's not Donald.
When he fought Anthony Pettis,
that's not Donald.
You can just tell he doesn't want to be in there.
This fight,
I couldn't really tell it was on the fence.
And then when he came out I was like,
oh no,
he's getting his ass whooped.
And then this huge jab drops,
drops Barboza and they ended up taking his back and he took some bombs before
that took some bombs.
He's getting picked apart.
Well,
he caught some crazy hooks.
He called and left kicks.
You could tell Barbara Rose had a speed advantage was mixing it up.
I was like,
oh no cowboy,
this isn't good.
And then drop them.
Then got his back,
jumped down on like a spider monkey,
got his back,
choked him out and everything's all good.
But now you got Habib number Grumet off.
Habib cause a mouth.
He's a rough,
Ravi was like rough,
rough.
Where's he from?
Day period?
They posted this full wrestle.
A grizzly bear at six ruff
was playing grab ass with the girls in the playground.
This fool's wrestling bears.
How can you compete with that head?
Thank God he's God.
He's at one 55 what's the fuck are we going to do?
He's so aggressive.
That fucking guy,
his grappling monster,
man,
he beat,
I mean he made those Angeles,
looked like they weren't in the same league.
Judge is bad ass.
Yeah,
he is.
Yeah.
The kids got ridiculous.
Grappling,
some of the best grappling I've ever seen inside the octagon.
Just so aggressive with his takedowns aggressive and changes things up,
changes angles and then gives you like a,
a difference in gears.
You know,
like he switches gears on you.
It was speeds up his approach,
slows it down,
drops down when you think he's going to stand up.
It just mixes it up.
Is He trains at eight k and asked dcs core Mia,
we do a show together UFC now.
And I asked him,
we were doing some breakdowns stuff on,
uh,
could be and I go,
is he that good?
He is,
he is man.
Cause you,
and you really haven't seen anything yet in the gym.
User stomp monster Samo was a great background.
It's one of the best
backgrounds ever for UFC agree because it's high level grappling.
It was a lot of really tough Russian guys.
You're competing against,
you're competing with fucking animals and these guys are really good at
transitioning as a sound,
but I didn't he um,
yeah,
he was combat sambo world champion.
Yeah.
It was kind of the face of it off.
That's not real.
There's an actual video of him as a kid rolling around with a fucking grizzly
bear and the grizzly bears like defending rear naked chokes and shit.
This grizzly bears like a blue belt in Jiu Jitsu.
I don't know where they found this big at the San Diego Zoo and I was watching
mountain gorillas wrestled the little mountain gorillas,
the adolescents and the baby.
They have great technique.
They're just natural wrestlers.
Here it is.
Oh,
really?
Brian,
while you were playing,
when you were dancing your ass off,
this guys wrestling with a beer.
Leave the bear double leg.
What?
That bear is an wait a minute.
That's not him.
Is it?
Is this the right video?
Youtube says.
I think so,
man.
Let's do one.
The UFC posted.
That's something he couldn't then Sabib confirmed it that it was him.
That he's a little kid,
little kid wrestling with the Goddamn bear.
That's insane.
Right?
That's so cool.
What kind of guy called and yelled at?
My Dad was a small buck,
was my best.
It's a baby bear still though.
Yeah,
it's still for sure.
I wouldn't fuck with that,
but they're looking,
that bears aggressive,
his shit too strong and it appears like dig in the rest of the role is that
though.
I want that.
Hey,
I want to bear badly.
Right,
because you'd ignore it and be in your backyard waiting [inaudible] come home
and then one day someone will go into your backyard and not know that the bear
likes to wrestle people and fucking take him down and scream and I just rode.
Yeah,
exactly.
I'm enough to have a bear.
That recipe not,
I'm not home enough to have a pair of the rest of the day.
I want so badly right now.
Not Home enough,
dude.
It's not fair.
Oh,
champs.
No bears.
Definitely.
No chimps.
It's just not fair when they're little.
Who's Johnny Hendricks?
Gonna fight against next?
Johnny Hendricks we'll fight.
Had a winner of [inaudible].
No,
Hector Lombard.
Nope.
Woodley and Roy and Roy MacDonald fight in June 14th on UFC one 74 that shut
Vancouver.
That's in Vancouver going to be there for that Brian Camp.
Yeah.
I can't wait the winner of that.
We'll get the next title fight.
I think Tyron Woodley is about as big as you can get.
And B,
one seven.
He's giant.
He's a beast.
He's a fucking strong kid too,
man.
Put that shit too.
But then you also got Jake,
Jake Ellenberger versus um,
are your boy Robbie Lawler is a tough one.
So many killers.
Like you start thinking about 71 71 55.
Y'all better have all your bases covered.
You've gotta be a black belt.
Can be a hell of an athlete on top of Angie [inaudible].
Tj Dillashaw fight,
right?
Isn't that the same card with Jake Ellenberger takes on Robbie Lawler.
What is this one 74 [inaudible] 74.
Oh yeah,
see Tj Dillashaw and Robbie Lawler or yeah,
they're on,
they're on the same
[inaudible] you can't get a picture up there.
And how about mighty mouse?
Man,
he might be the best pound for pound guy on the of planet.
He's good.
You might be the most technical pound for pound fighter in the plant.
I mean,
everybody always turns to the big ones.
Beaning Barao Joe say Aldo and Jon Jones.
But the smaller you go,
the more talented they are.
My mouth.
I agree.
It might be the best.
Rarely knocked out Benevidez with the flux on that comment.
Who's ever done that,
but you don't see too many knockouts,
especially at that level.
And he tastes guys down.
Submits them to in the fourth round against Morocco and he went to war with John
Moraga,
then went to war.
He eventually,
you know,
it's overcoming them with with technique and then he catches them on the ground.
What is it heading the fight and he's still finishing him with an arm bar.
It's crazy and barrancas fucking dangerous.
Berakah caught him clean with a straight punch right to the mug and he ate it
readjusted.
Yup.
Great fight back.
Good fight.
Really.
He's fucking technical shit man.
He's technical launch.
Really technical and just does having that Guy Matt Hume as your trainer from
jump from,
it's so big.
It's huge.
Like I know so much to base for you.
Right.
And they know so much.
First of all,
he was a very good fighter himself.
Moist,
both Moitai Jiu Jitsu.
He did MMA,
fought in a,
I think he fought an extreme fighting.
He fought pat military.
She's stopped Pat Miller to distribute the,
broke his nose with a neat old school.
He's really good.
But his knowledge,
he also was a judge and pride for a long time.
Judged a lot of fights in prod.
You would always see Matt,
he was stoic look guy.
He would,
the way he behaved,
he's just always struck me as very stoic like smart dude.
Yeah.
That was a lot of shit about fighting.
You hear him in the corner when he's given advice to some of the best advice
you'll ever hear.
Really?
Yeah.
Very technical.
Very uh,
very much you could tell that they've trained for a very specific style of,
of game plan and how to adjust,
you know,
makes adjustments.
Has a plant's be plans.
Like you could tell like the way there when he's talking about Dj and uh,
when he was fighting Benevidez,
you know,
the Bellevue is loading up,
like they saw it coming.
What's,
what's weird to meet.
We're not weird,
but what's cool is the relationship between coaches and fighters.
Like a coach would know what to say to a fighter,
right?
Like some guys need to be hyped up.
Some guys need to be hyped up where the coach is yelling and screaming.
I'm in between rounds doing stuff like that.
That can be super negative and then other ones are super calm,
relaxed,
very Greg Jackson is,
and just the difference between,
that's crazy.
When I was on the ultimate fighter at a coach,
yell at me and slap the shit,
slapped me so hard it,
it literally rocked me before walking in the octagon.
He slapped me so hard.
It's a little spazzy.
It was like,
come on,
let's go.
That's not,
that isn't working.
I was like,
Trevor Whitman,
did he really?
I was like,
Huh.
I see out of his fucking life literally doing and that when the octagon,
you went down to the right,
what are we doing that works with clay?
Guido?
Maybe like his brother [inaudible] brother only slaps him like 20% he's not like
really cocky him in the head.
He's just slap,
slap,
slap and get him.
I mean,
he's not hurting his brother,
right?
Yeah.
Some guys
like that.
Like if you watch box and if you watch that Garcia,
who's a the,
what's the name of Madonna?
Madonna.
Yeah.
Robert Garcia.
Have you seen the way he coaches guys?
Very good.
Very good coach.
A great coach.
He works with Kane recently.
Instead of cane took three years off.
He could be heavyweight champion.
Wow.
It's a boxer.
Yeah.
Three years.
I'll have to get them,
get them the right fights,
build them up strong for three years.
He'd be heavyweight.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I mean the heavy,
the heavyweight boxing pictures please.
Bladimir Ma,
what is his name?
Cloudberry.
He's a beast.
He's a fucking beast.
Is a very good boxer.
Klitschko yes.
No one.
No one in MMA.
Searing a peep out of Klitschko.
He's going to destroy guys.
So how was,
uh,
how was Robert Garcia think that came to Alaska is going to beat Klitschko well,
what else is he going to say?
I mean,
if this boy,
I don't know.
That's a stretch.
It's an interesting thing.
It,
I would like to see them try to do it.
I would think that'd be fascinating to see what he could do a lot of reach to
deal with for cane.
By the way,
a lot of rich those clips goes fight
very few punches.
They,
the pitch goes just that,
that jab and then really conservative.
I have a buddy,
this is a funny story about the Klitschkos have a very good friend.
I played college football was when I first came to la.
He was dating,
uh,
at the,
it's Klitschkos fiance now or why?
I know they got married,
Hayden penitentiary.
He was dating her and uh,
he's gonna kill me for telling this story.
I won't tell a story then.
Well,
it's not too bad.
It's not too bad.
So,
so he,
he,
he's dating this girl.
Klich gone her are not dating and he thinks he's all paranoid.
He's all worried cause fricking Klitschko.
And so he,
uh,
cars behind him and he doesn't know if this is true or not,
but he thinks Klitschko Hasko and tailor them.
You know what I'm saying?
So he calls me up,
Bro,
get over here,
man.
I think something's bad to go down for.
You know me.
I'm like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
he's about to go down.
He goes,
I think you know I'm dating this girl.
I think her ex boyfriend at the time,
I had no idea who was dating or what he's talking about.
He goes,
I think your ex boyfriends trailing Nagel.
Who the fuck's her ex boyfriend?
He was Klitschko they'll fight the heavyweight boxer.
He goes,
Yo,
I'm not fucking coming down there.
He goes,
yeah bro,
you can take them now.
No,
I liked that die.
And if you're talking with this girl,
that's what she can't,
man.
No Man,
I got the phone.
Six six two 43.
It's a baby boy.
It,
man,
that's a lot to tell it.
And uh,
just one ridiculous fifth round,
you know who we should be talking about is Bernard Hopkins at 49 one another
title.
It's so ridiculous.
How's he doing that?
Brenton Chubb.
How the fuck is he doing that?
How's it Bernard Hopkins winning titles are 49.
Tell me.
He's training smart and it just is Reenie ring experience.
He's just destroying youngsters.
Right?
But isn't that incredible?
49 years old.
Incredible thing.
How good.
How could it be?
Straight training.
I agree.
Speeding guys in his twenties I can't explain it.
He's destroying guys.
I can't explain it.
He dropped the dude in the 11th round circles.
He looks a little old in that picture.
Look at him.
He's just going to say,
don't look that old.
He was old enough.
It's just the grain.
His beard,
he shave his beard off.
He doesn't look old at all.
I agree.
So weird thing.
How three weeks,
but he's doing something that nobody's done in sports.
It ever maybe.
Well,
he's also said that he doesn't need to work out the way everybody works out.
Like everybody has this idea that you have to work out hours every day.
He goes,
I was every day for 30 minute fight.
Like why?
You got to work out hours every day.
So he's figured out how to maintain enough fitness to go a 30 minute fights.
That's all he does.
All he has to do is get in shape.
Yup.
What's he gonna do?
What are they gonna do?
[inaudible] he's Mass Boston.
He's putting his 10,000 hours.
He's mastered boxing and now he just and stayed.
He's never been really hurt.
He's never been really like Malden knocked out,
knocked out.
And as far as the training goes,
it's,
it's funny to me,
I was,
I had this strength condition coach.
I still work with them.
Andre would are crazy and he would make be trained for an hour and a half.
The circuit,
we do like 12 rounds,
these circuit crazy ass things and I'm loving it.
Right.
I just love to work.
I'm doing it.
And this guy who doesn't know shit about the FC nursing EOC goes,
what are you getting ready for man?
I got a fight coming up.
He goes,
Oh yeah,
a 12 round fight,
huh?
No,
no,
that's only three rounds.
He goes,
oh,
like 10 minute rounds or you know,
they're a three five minute rounds.
He goes,
and you've been here for about,
you've been here longer than me,
man.
I'm,
how long have you been [inaudible]?
I'm an hour and a half.
He goes,
oh,
that's cool.
And I could tell he was like,
what?
And then went into the locker room.
I was like,
this guy is totally right.
Jackass who has no idea what the fuck are we doing.
So I sat down with my coach and was like,
Yo man,
my fights,
15 minutes been in for an hour and a half doing all this crazy shit.
We need to cut that down.
Tim Ferriss did this,
like he looked at how much Olympic track athletes when they're,
when the strength training and they lift heavy weights to lot.
He was took a look at how much they actually are spending.
Like if you actually time,
the amount of time they're lifting weights for the weights are in the air.
It's something really crazy.
Like 20 minutes a month.
Like it's very,
very little there.
They're maxing out.
But then that's different though.
That's just
a little different weights though.
It doesn't take day.
No,
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying it doesn't like for strength training when they're trying to get
stronger.
What's interesting is that power lifting and stuff,
they don't lift as much nearly as much as you think,
eh.
You know,
it's,
it's the right,
that's not what he's talking about at all.
Well,
he's fighting.
He's talking about to overtrain.
No,
no,
no.
He's talking about rounds where you're fighting like it's totally unrelevant.
Well,
what I'm saying is they hold up over Crisco
chaos.
Look up Vladimir Klitschko
returns three belts and ESPN.
You got to see the highlight of him fucking stop.
And that dude,
what's amazing about Bernard Hopkins is that he's able to control the pace of
every fight he gets in.
Even if the guy's really good,
he's able to control the pace of the fight.
Like to know his diet.
Yeah.
What are we doing here?
Well,
he's very into healthy foods.
You know,
he doesn't eat anything processed.
He doesn't need anything stupid.
He doesn't drink.
He doesn't do drugs.
She doesn't fuck around hardy or anything.
He was Floyd Mayweather doesn't drink,
doesn't do drugs.
Smart when he,
but he doesn't eat fast food.
That drives me nuts.
Yeah.
I think probably a lot of it he does for the to camera.
I think he's being silly.
I bet he does a lot of it for the camera.
What did this look at?
Klitschko
look at that.
That Jack,
he's so big,
man,
he just so long and tall.
Check this shit out.
Does light up,
tink tink.
He's so long,
dude.
He sold.
Like I said,
you get one shot and it's in front of millions of people for a lot of money
in Hopkins.
Hopkins beat Kelly Pavlick and after the fight he grabbed him and they said,
what'd you say it?
He goes,
he said what?
He said in his hair as he goes,
don't let this ruin you.
Like in other words,
I outclass to completely and you are a hit man and a killer.
And he goes,
don't let this ruin tele.
Pavlik had a problem with alcohol.
That was as big as I only had happened apparently.
No,
it's weird.
I always had a problem with that.
Everyone knows a hitman is still a killer.
It's gonna be tough to be a champion to have alcohol issue.
Yeah,
you can [inaudible] you guys got like Bernard Hopkins who's going to bed at 7:00
PM.
You know what I'm saying?
Waking up at six running and shit.
I'm just saying that Barry was still a killer.
Same areas,
but not hot.
But meanwhile,
you know,
you do boxing math the same as you try to do a MMA math.
Uh,
Jermaine Taylor beat Hopkins twice.
Yep.
And Kelly Pavlik knocked out Jermaine Taylor.
It's weird.
Yeah,
it is.
It's,
it's boxing,
math and it's also,
I think Kelly Pavlik caught Jermaine Taylor after Jermaine Taylor had had his
bell rung enough.
There's a number.
Well,
you've just,
you hit the wall and there's no coming back.
And when Pavlik stopped him,
it was one of those,
Ooh,
this might be the end.
It was one of those where you see the end of a fighter's career sometimes in one
stoppage.
He,
no,
not always.
Right.
Like packy Al came back after the mark has knocked out.
A lot of people predicted he would never,
a lot of people said,
this is it,
this is the end.
But he's got a really fucking smart trainer and Freddie Roach,
he said,
take a year off.
Took a whole year.
So he wasn't even boxing and he didn't know contact for long.
Freddie.
And uh,
George started to be the same way towards the end of his career.
They only spar and camp and Freddy only smart.
Has this guys sparked the last four weeks before a fight?
Smart.
Is that super smart?
Yeah.
I don't understand the logic because sparring so important.
You're doing Mitt work.
You don't admit we're doing everything on combination and you can actually go up
in cause it feels like when
somebody is hitting you back,
well when you're at that level,
what do it same with the NFL when you're at that level,
why take Bron brain trauma and the NFL,
most of them don't hit during during the season.
They only hit on Sundays.
Listen,
if you can't fucking make a tackle on Monday you're sure as shit and I can make
it on Sunday when it counts with Freddie Roach does with his fighters.
If you watch like any of those Hbo,
24 Sevens,
I love them.
They can sell me on anything.
Yeah,
they're great.
He does a lot of positions.
I kilter out tap and then step hook and they'll go over this,
this one particular combination that they feel is gonna apply to their opponent
over and over and over again.
And they develop it so that it becomes like sort of a secondary reflex.
So they'll,
they'll do a lot of like specific stuff for each individual fighter.
The 24 seven has kind of it,
it was at an a plus.
I give it an a minus now B plus cause all access on showtime.
Floyd Mayweather took his business there.
If you watch last night,
episode three with soy may then Ms. Jackson is in the picture anymore.
And you know why he released it today?
So it,
Ms. Jackson was his main chick right forever.
She was on all the countdowns,
whatever.
This pretty girl take him shop and show her like in Protestant and all this
money,
whoop whoop,
whoop whoop.
And then she's not there anymore.
He's like,
we just had our differences.
She's not around anymore.
So Twitter was blown up like Yo why,
what's wrong with Ms. Jackson?
I guess she was talking shit about Floyd.
So Floyd is like,
what?
This is what happened.
She was pregnant with twins and decide to have an abortion without my consent.
I want to have these babies.
She had an abortion without my consent.
That's why we're not fucking together.
And then she is,
yeah,
get ready for this.
Then she on Instagram is Jackson posts a picture talking shit to Floyd with her
new man Nelly.
Right.
I'm all into this shit by the way.
I'm like TMZ and the fight world of it.
So then she posts pictures with Nellie and then Floyd's like he a picture.
Yeah.
Ms. Jackson looks great.
Before I paid for all these fucking plastic surgeries,
shows the picture of her just busted,
just straight up busted like in the morning,
just one eye open.
Just a real warlocks state in the morning,
posted that picture and then he took it down though.
He took it down.
When you're having an Instagram fight that's kind of,
that's pretty low.
It's not enough.
It's not good.
But that's,
people love it.
Dot out there that she had an abortion with his twins,
his heart.
I think he was getting so much backlash.
Like what the,
Oh,
you're too good,
blah blah.
So he's like,
what are should I think she said something to interview,
so he's like,
oh,
really?
Checked this sound.
Bam,
that fight.
He had dad.
Dad comes over and they start talking and out of nowhere they're both rack room.
That's rough.
Chicken ads.
Chicken had to get you a Floyd Mayweather and fuck with him.
He's,
he's mastered chicken head.
He has a black belt.
Chicken heads.
I'm a blue belt.
It's much more than a chicken head,
don't you think?
That's a,
that's a really crazy situation.
She can head.
That's a chicken that's been together a long time.
That's that's
because they were together and she was allowed to have all the side pieces.
That's how I become Ms. Jackson.
That's how you've kind of Ms. Floyd Mayweather.
She accepted that lifestyle and then she wanted to do her own modeling thing and
all this stuff,
so he suspended her from the countdown show just before she was an on there and
they asked why.
He goes,
you know what she just said to prove her worth.
She was getting little too big for her Britches,
so I have to suspend it from the countdown show.
That'd be a chicken head.
He has a black belt and chicken heads.
Boise knees step your game up.
You're suspended.
It's so fucked when you involve babies and stuff into that equation and try to
figure out like where where that,
how that factored in.
You know what point are you like,
listen,
I'm the king of chicken heads.
Bitch.
You're suspended from the countdown shows.
Who has that talk?
Hey listen,
all access to be here and we need to get out.
Why you acting like chicken head?
Get the hell Outta here.
Wow,
that's hilarious.
Managing your employees chicken,
I guess man,
shop.
You got a pair of,
I just want to bring it to the attention of the listeners.
It you're wearing a pair of fairy tied camouflage camouflage shorts.
I really appreciate that.
No shocks.
Yeah,
you're very happy with the legs and those Camo shorts though.
Let's talk about the,
I met those quads,
son.
Hmm.
That's a shit.
Low slung,
low slung tank top.
Yeah.
Well my Dick's hanging out the front.
It's whatever the necklace.
Yeah,
it is.
It is sad when you see those fucking relationships,
those crazy relationships,
especially when there are aired in front of 20 million so dark,
like what you're doing,
you know,
just started.
The cameras are on and he starts talking about abortion.
Listen.
Oh.
They say that's Floyd's biggest problem is women.
Ah,
yeah.
It's every famous athletes problem is people like you start to see what they're
really about as as the,
as the theme starts to wane,
like Bruce Jenner deciding that he's going to go transgender.
There's that for sure.
Now,
is he really trying?
No,
no,
he's not.
Brian,
you just making that up and you're going to get in trouble.
What do you mean I'm getting in trouble?
I thought even now that I did,
I did hear that.
You seen the video?
Have you seen the pictures?
Rumors,
man.
It's just rumors.
Have you done research on this?
You're talking about a man's body and his aspirations from Pete towards being
another woman.
There's no statements.
There's nothing you're going to find online.
I'm going to say Jenga.
Say this.
Ready?
I'm going to say,
I'll tell you this.
He says mining a Malibu.
I'm gonna say this right now.
Listen Up.
Okay.
I know somebody very well.
Very well.
I gotta be careful,
but I know somebody very well.
Please be careful who is very close to that family.
Okay,
and should you be saying this for sure?
I think it's okay.
Okay.
I'm being general.
And they told me and I said the same thing you said,
I went that,
are you crazy?
Take a look please.
Let's take a look.
I went,
that could just be him in the middle
of a conversation and he makes a fucking weird face.
And then someone captured it and then put it up and made it like it was a bit,
hopefully the week.
Hold on,
hold on,
please.
Hold on.
Please hold.
Hold.
So I went.
Interesting.
Why are you talking about this guy?
Why are you even focusing on his sexuality?
Oh,
I'm just,
what is it?
Why are you getting all politically,
you don't know the guy.
I find it very interesting,
but you don't know him.
So I just think it's interesting and surprising that that Bruce Jenner,
maybe so what were the facts they toasting to what would they see?
The fact that he has decided he is going to go,
uh,
transgender.
Come on and I sent it and,
and,
and then subsequently I've read it.
Well,
it might be the,
that you streams down.
Do you know that it keeps cutting off?
Jimmy might be,
no,
no.
We're not looking that up.
And Jesus fucking Christ.
How do you suddenly get the guys that have about one thing?
I don't know the guy,
you don't know him.
You don't know his scenario.
You have never talked to anyone about it.
It's surprising.
It looks odd,
but you may not know whether it be a transgender,
his skin is very tight and he might,
he might very well,
I find it peculiar that you would spend any time what so ever contemplating
storing this,
finding your friends names so that we can get this out while being as vague as
possible.
I'm very vague and to maybe is it would explain how he's able to hang out with
those squawking hands all day.
Only one would tell it.
Talk about the chicken heads.
He's the only one with talent.
I don't have all those bitches in that house.
He just needs to look around,
be like,
ah no,
we're the only reasonable he bitches or here's cause I have talent.
Can we acknowledge that's not true.
The reason why they're there is to,
she did porn and she was friends with Paris Hilton and her mom was the architect
of a lot of it.
Yeah.
And there her mom was married to Robert Kardashian who was a famous lawyer.
There's a lot involved there.
Oj Chicken head excuses though.
But he was already like long past his fame.
Yes.
When he came back with this,
I mean there was no one who,
no one was hanging out talking about how great Bruce Jenner was.
It just never came out and get into movies after,
after the Olympics.
So he got,
he did this,
you got to know this job and did you get a nose job is no,
this is very,
very different than it used to be.
Very different.
And um,
and it didn't work out.
It didn't work out.
And,
uh,
and then,
I don't know,
you're going to keep trying to put it in anyway.
I mean,
I think the,
I think what the Kardashians have done,
I think the mom is a genius marketing genius.
Well those girls,
and run with it like this.
Then the,
see Ryan Seacrest's got behind them and then Bam,
they're like,
now every girl wants to be them.
That's not good for a girl.
It's only dummies.
It's only dummies in,
they're young and they don't know any better cause it looks glamorous and she's
got all the nice stuff that everybody wants.
It's hard to get,
but it doesn't mean that it's,
it's,
it's kind of like the porn star thing where,
where,
um,
it's not tied to accomplishment.
The,
it's the wrong kind of in an attention.
You can make that argument.
Well,
he's a porn star.
Could just like show awesome Dick Sucking technique where you just want to jump
off to.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it's about Kara.
Kara was like,
let's be honest,
it's not really a talent.
She goes,
it's not really a skillset.
It's not a skill.
You're kind of born fucking,
she goes,
I was always fucking,
and she was always very sexual and now she does not on camera,
you know?
Yeah.
But some girls are bad at it.
So it is a talent.
It's a talent or is it a skill?
Like if I,
if I played golf,
every dad be pretty damn good.
If I was,
if I was a girl jacking guys off so I can dig out and get pretty good.
Okay,
let's,
let's Google,
what's the difference between talent and skill?
Because I'm not entirely sure.
Well,
town will,
you were born God deal.
You can work at scale is something that you work at getting better at.
Now I'm not buying that because some people have no talent in the beginning and
then they work at it and then people go,
wow,
that's a skill and talent.
Sometimes you see somebody who's,
who's getting a ring in their boxer and you go,
you got talent,
you could actually be good.
Whereas you see somebody who doesn't have town and you go,
you're gonna have to go.
You're going to have to work really hard and develop skill to make up for your
talent.
Here's how it's described.
Online talent is usually an innate ability to do something.
While skill is a learned ability to do something that's weird.
Talent is the natural aspect that needs a little nudge to realize while skill
requires investment of a lot of time talent,
and then the really scary thing is when talented people develop skills,
that's when you get a Jon Jones,
Mike Tyson.
Yeah,
that's the difference.
Or these porn stars you're talking about that or girl who just can take tongue
to the ball.
Just la La.
Why?
How has she been able to do that without throwing up?
How is she doing a lot of skill involved?
Lot of expense skill.
A lot of reading.
Well,
also as somebody who has such a huge fan base because you believe her face,
like she,
I was talking to about that,
her acting,
her ability to make you think she's really enjoying it is Brian thinks this
girl's a legit,
like I finished talking to her for an hour and that's what we were talking
about.
So she's a freak.
Yeah.
This is,
people are not,
they shouldn't be porn stars.
And then there's people that go,
oh yeah.
Well you're good at it.
Yeah.
You're good at it.
But she,
yeah,
she does some hardcore stuff too.
I'm not familiar with it.
It's not light.
I wasn't either.
She doesn't matter.
Easy Shola podcasts.
Oh really?
The one we were at really?
She had this book and I read it and I said,
come on,
read her whole book.
Yeah.
It's really easy.
It's funny actually.
It's like short.
No,
but she's so honest.
Could we,
oh my God.
Is she honest about it?
Did you read it naked?
I did read it naked in horse stance.
It a
bestseller book just came out.
Can you just came out?
Huh?
I Dunno.
You know,
they say now Kreischer was saying that the book selling business so fucked and
so bad that unless there's preorders like,
like they,
the amount of books that they put out,
unless there's a ton of preorders they barely bought wound up putting them on
shelves or bringing them to bookstores and things along those lines because
people,
it's really hard.
I'm kindle and all that.
They're getting from that and it just not buying that many books,
man.
Peter,
we're just not buying that many fucking books.
That's how it gets signed.
Yeah.
I'm going to let everybody know that Ustream crashed.
You're having a real bad problem with this computer right now.
Bandwidth.
Audio's still going good.
So okay.
I'm just let everybody,
Ustream is shit the bed.
We'll be back soon.
We'll be actually soon.
If possible.
We'll be back soon.
Okay.
So,
uh,
do you guys,
do you guys plan on doing anything with the fighter and the kid we take it to
like,
or a network or take it to somewhere else?
Well,
we just got the numbers back and they're good,
right?
They're good.
So it's time to start making some moves.
Yeah.
You got to do something where you could swear.
I'm just gonna tell you right now,
every time we get together and we do a podcast,
I'm going to tell you,
you got to stop doing this nonsense where they tell you what you can and can't
say.
You got to stop.
You Go,
you go.
You're,
you're dirty comedian.
You're a cage fighter,
so you can't,
you can't censor that.
What kind of nonsense is this?
This is ridiculous.
We agree.
It's an argument that comedian,
a fucking cage fighter and telling me what pocket put on the air that the last
podcast,
we did talk about broken decks yesterday.
Yeah.
No broken desc stories on the,
I know Brooke can dig stories.
My friend texts me,
he goes,
you son of a pastor.
You told us that no one knows it's you.
Everyone knew it was all our friends and family knew.
It was one of the greatest broken dick stories of all time.
Damn right.
Everybody knows somebody who knows somebody broke the deck.
It's one of those things.
It's well as things.
You don't want to be that guy though.
Fuck.
You live in in Scotland.
You know somebody who knows somebody who's seen the loch ness monster.
Yeah.
There's not a,
this is not a bad broken Dick's story out there.
By the way.
Every broker,
all story makes you go,
oh no,
no.
It's usually an aggressive grows on top was just really crazy.
You would think the guy would like that.
Straight Elephant Dick.
I'll see.
It's long and if you think it's going to break in the middle like a twig,
it's not good.
You a short stubby Dick would be way harder to break in the middle of say for if
you're going to be promiscuous like shorts,
you have a long piece of metal,
you can bend it.
Exactly.
If you have something you want a short stubby,
you try bending the lighter sized piece of metal.
It's hard to dance very hard working with like a monster Ding Dong here.
You know what I'm saying?
It doesn't have to be monster.
All it has to do is just hit that taint at the right angle.
Bang,
like a fucking Ferrari that hits one of those jersey barriers.
Ben's the frame.
Ah,
AH,
ugh.
Fucking bloods pooling up and your ball neither.
You guys ever broke your Dick?
Not even close.
My Dick is bulletproof by the way.
It's not going to break.
I have not.
I've not.
I was always careful about that stuff.
I don't always hold up watching.
Everybody calmed down
and then I did.
It grows a bite.
Your face,
your lips and I'm like,
hey,
that really hurts and makes me angry.
Not attractive role.
I have a girlfriend.
When I first started fighting for whatever reason,
she started hitting me.
Oh my God.
Like abusive.
But like we say something like,
well that's stupid.
She be like,
Babe,
like that's fucking hitting.
Where was she hitting you?
What part of your body?
She'd hit me in the chest.
Ship me in the arm.
Not In the face.
That gets weird.
That'd been chicken head hit me in the face of your chicken to chicken out if
she hits you.
Yes.
A little bit.
Chicken,
chicken had characteristics.
You should.
You have a chicken head tee shirt,
dude,
you should sell a to it.
He Shit.
Chicken heads fighter.
A fighter in the kid
or just have a chicken that a voice like a chicken head Trevor chicken head at
all costs.
Avoid at all costs.
Yeah,
and just just a chicken head.
Don't have a severed chicken head though.
Cause now that's two and two.
I don't want that.
It's sort of like it fades off like no one.
Just draw the chicken head and that's it.
You know what I mean?
Anything else?
She was the head bottom was like,
no,
no.
You could do a chicken head and then just as Bob Banging this body in a bikini,
that's good.
The fighter and the kid shop.com that's the answer.
[inaudible] heads at all costs.
Yeah.
That's a great idea.
Boy,
that might be the most sexist shirt has ever sexist.
Knowing women are going to be angry at that.
Well
it doesn't matter.
Women will do something that men won't do,
whereas they'll gang up and go after a guy who shitting on any type of woman.
True.
Whereas men,
if you,
if there's a group of women that are making fun of a man,
like,
or a type of man,
we don't give a fuck.
[inaudible]
actually stay really quiet.
Oh,
sorry about that.
Then we won't attack.
When Sharon Osborne,
you know,
she has that showed the talk and they were talking about a guy who got his dick
cut off and the girl through the Dick in the garbage disposal and they were
laughing about it.
She was laughing about his Willie spinning around in the garbage disposal.
That's the funding.
I imagine if there was a show where a guy was laughing because he heard a story
about a woman getting her vagina cutoff and the guy throwing it in a garbage
should be canceled.
It would be a fucking right.
If Dr Phil did that,
she'll be canceled.
Yeah,
I,
it would be a pariah forever.
She's suffered no repercussions for it.
That is different thing.
Well,
it's not our Dick.
It's not a dick.
We don't care.
But if it's a woman,
you know,
and I get it because it's more likely that a man is going to assault a woman
than a woman's going to salt the man.
But you can't laugh when a woman in salts assaults a man and expect people
to be just peace,
love,
and nirvana throughout the sexes,
the genders.
That's a man hating shit,
man.
And An InSinkErator.
I mean,
it's dark as dark.
Damn.
That's a nasty fight.
What happened was the guy that she drugged him,
she drugged,
she put him to sleep and she cut his dick off.
Then she threw the garbage disposal.
She might be clippers,
chicken cheating.
I don't know.
I think he was leaving her.
I don't,
oh my God.
But that show,
whatever it was,
she,
she's Sharon Osborne laughing about his Dick Spinning around in a circle.
She could,
I could just see as willy spouse.
Sharon Osborne was in Vegas.
I was looking,
I was looking for some shoes and she got the guy who cooks.
Can I see some id?
I was right there and she goes,
go fuck herself.
And her,
the guy she was with,
she walked out.
He goes,
what happened?
And she goes,
she asked me Friday.
I didn't know I was,
I told him to go fuck himself.
I heard that with my own.
I don't gossip and I and I,
when I saw that I went,
that's an asshole move.
That's a Shitty,
that's shit.
That's not cool.
That's a big time.
That was rude.
Relax.
That's a pair of lavender and I saw,
I heard anyone in this world is famous enough to do that.
That's not cool.
Then what is she famous for?
Exactly.
It'd be an,
I don't know.
I ain't know it was her at first.
Then I was like,
reality shows legit on MTV.
I love,
she's married to Ozzy Osborne who was totally out of it.
Yeah,
I mean literally dragged up the whole time.
Shit.
Right.
Shaking all over the place.
Shit in his pants.
You want,
she's killed.
She's totally on the ball.
She's on the ball and he's off the ball.
True.
She was having a bad day.
She has those extra hungry eyes.
Super Thirsty for Dick.
That's what it looked like.
Is that what you got out of it?
That's what
I don't know what she does.
I have no idea.
She's doing well though.
Well,
she made a lot of money with Ozzie.
Sure.
I just think that's a bummer when people treat others.
It is a bond,
man.
A thumb me out.
Yep.
I even said to the guy goes,
is that the,
did she do what I thought?
And they had the guy who worked at that store.
Was that w.
W what point do you get like that though?
When things are going to face is having a bad day?
Have you ever pulled the famous card?
Never.
Joe's never liked that.
I'm not that guy.
I think that most famous,
completely legitimate and just random and lucky.
I'm,
I'm much more impressed with talented people that people don't know.
Then I usually am with talented people that are really famous.
You know?
I think talent is what impresses me.
If someone happens to be famous and talented,
that's more like,
wow,
that's interesting.
Let's see how this guy manages it,
but I don't look at him like they're better anyway.
Anybody thinks that just because you're famous,
you're a better person or someone should know you.
People ask me my name all the time when I know they know my name and I always
assume that it's either because they're not sure.
You know that maybe they don't know MMA that well and they think I'm Dana White.
Like I've had people call me Dana white cause they know there's some sort of a
weird connection and UFC like they ran,
they barely watch it and I'll make that mistake.
Or you're wearing a suit too.
I was saying that sometimes you got to be careful like,
like I don't know what happened was Sean Osmo,
maybe she was in a having a terrible day or something like that.
Make,
excuse me,
watching everything.
They watch everything you do and some days you can just do something you regret.
You know I fucked up in a,
he could have been that the guy was being a dick too.
It could have been the guy was doing a power move knows and she knew what the
fuck was going on.
I had this lady totally pull a power move on me once.
She was one of the security people at an arena and a,
I was running in and I had my,
uh,
my UFC tag on and she like stopped me and wanted to see id as well as in like
all these other things that,
and everybody around her was working with and starts laughing,
you know,
like bitch,
you know who that is?
Like the guy who was working with her,
it goes,
you know who that is?
Like let them through.
And she's like,
ah,
you know,
I need to see this now.
But it was weird.
It was like she just decided and she was just like really aggressive.
It's her moment
sometimes I'm not famous,
right.
I'm not that famous at all,
but sometimes can work against you.
Like I went to,
you guys can clown me all you want.
And I told Brian and I went to go buy a Prius on Saturday,
right.
To do that because I drive 600 miles.
I average 600 miles a week in training camp.
So I bought a Prius just for the 50 miles a gallon.
I still have my m six.
Don't get it twisted.
It's got them sick and drives that Prius.
I can,
I'm saying,
yeah,
I do.
I drive the shit thing.
The wheels are gonna fall off any second,
however that Prius,
right.
50 miles a gallon.
So when I go the deal,
I'm taking pictures with the dealers,
stuff like that.
Well they think because you're on TV,
you're this instant mega millionaire.
Right.
And I,
I brought my coach with me.
I told him,
I was like,
either because they know who I am looking at hooked me up or they're going to be
like,
no,
this guy is bawling.
Just fucking rob rob them.
So when they come up,
I'm like,
oh cool man.
Uh,
you let sit down.
I obviously want to fucking Prius.
So we're sitting there,
they come back some ridiculous number.
It totally backfired,
man.
But eventually,
you know what hustled and got him down.
But in general it backfires.
I feel like because the people think,
oh,
this guy doesn't care.
He has all this money.
He doesn't care what,
what,
what number?
Whatever number we bring him,
he's going to pay for it.
Wow.
Yeah.
That definitely can happen.
They can definitely target you.
They feel like you're a score.
That's just someone who's an idiot who doesn't understand personal relations,
don't you?
Don't you know,
you,
you ruined the city.
Like you don't think the guy knows that you are,
you're doing that.
I've had,
I had a guy tried to sell me a car for $10,000 more than it was advertised on
the Internet.
Really?
Yeah.
Like I went to a deal and I was asking him about cars while back and uh,
and I go,
I'm like,
what do you,
what do you guys sell in this for?
I asked when I knew the answer and d homeboy hit me with a $10,000 over the
figure online and I go,
you sure?
And he goes,
yeah,
well how come it says different online?
And then he goes ghost pale.
Cause he was a fucking asshole.
He was a,
he was a guy who was hoping that I didn't pay attention and he could just knock
another 10,000.
Dot.
Hey,
I got it for 10,000 over the price,
pull it off the Internet quick.
Yeah.
All that,
that type of thing.
In terms of short term phase two,
that's what I took it as.
To me it was like,
dude,
come on man.
Idiot man.
I mean,
come on.
No,
an honest mistake for 100% when you confront someone famous,
Donald's a philosophy where you walk into the room and uh,
when did their store and you're considered worth $54,000.
What does that mean?
The average person who is a Mcdonald's customer,
I don't know if this 20 more,
it would spend over a lifetime about $54,000.
So when you walk in,
you wouldn't Mcdonald's,
yes,
you are not a meal.
So is that like in their book?
So you're not a meal.
What you are is your worth not that hamburger.
You are worth $54,000 over our lifetime and it's called longterm thinking.
Right.
So a lot of companies will talk about that like Dell,
Dell assess what the,
what the repeat customers worth over a lifetime and it's a big number and that's
the way to run a business.
And when you start thinking short term,
greedy and go,
I can get this guy for you know,
$1,000 extra.
You're being stupid.
That is a good idea.
But the best idea is to take it one step further.
Not just fucking be nice to be born [inaudible] $54,000 bill.
You don't have to think of it like that.
Just be nice to people and try to put out a good sort of vibe,
play tool call doing the right thing and fire people that act like dicks but the
managers at Dick,
get rid of them.
Tell everybody that works there.
Listen,
I'm looking to hire nice,
friendly people.
I want an environment that's positive for everybody to work in.
Everybody's having a good time.
It's not good enough.
Just be good at your job.
You have to also be a nice person.
If you're not a nice person,
I'm really not interested in working with you.
Are you a nice person and if they liked s I'm going to go to windows and they
just fucking mumble and leave.
You know what though?
Some people act out of fear and if you explain to them the philosophy behind why
to be ethical in that sense,
sometimes it can help them cause I just have set goals,
friendly,
being nice.
You know,
being nice should be mandatory.
Yes.
That's,
I mean it's pretty common sense.
Don't be an asshole.
Well it's also,
it's not though.
You know,
it should be well be everybody's in competition with everybody else.
And it's like there's certain people that at a certain point in time it's like
when we're talking about the guy in the gym that's mad dog in you,
you know,
because you did it girl,
he's a bitch.
You know?
So when you,
when you run into certain guys that are weak in character,
their own insecurity,
we allow that word stuff in,
in acting stuff too.
Like real people.
Yeah.
Where people will get really,
really bummed out because somebody else got successful and they get all right.
Worried or mean about it and realize like,
why are you focusing on that?
Why the fuck
he's cause good somebody else's and just focus on your own thing.
Why are you focusing on somebody else?
So they don't know.
Well,
they don't know how to think and they've got a pattern there.
The stuck in a bad pattern.
I had a girl speaking of just not being nice out of girl who people warned me
about or like listen to it.
She's not that cool.
It's kind of a bitch.
And I was like,
I don't see it super friendly to me.
We go this Thai restaurant straight,
you know,
traditional Thai restaurant and the lady taking the order didn't speak very good
English and the my date while she's trying or this stuff,
the lady was like,
uh,
say it again,
right?
Like in whatever broken English and this,
my date starts laughing at her,
making fun of her.
I was like,
what?
No,
no,
never saw her gas finish that meal.
She's like,
so we going to the movie,
not,
I'll feel good.
It just bounce again.
What's that growth?
What's it going wrote?
That book has said,
look,
make sure you advice to women.
Pay attention to how the man you're with treats.
The waiter because that treats you well girls.
Two girls.
Two people would treat people badly when they don't have to.
When it's an opportunity to be nice to people,
right?
People tip badly.
If I see someone tipping badly,
I lose massive respect for them.
Especially someone with money.
I see a guy with money who's doing well for himself,
who is really cheap with the tip or takes money back,
puts my down,
thinks about and then take some back.
Oh it's dark.
That's dark,
dark,
just dark.
Cause this is like everything you don't want to see in a person.
Selfish,
short minded,
shithead like you're doing well does.
You don't have money concern right now.
You don't have money concern.
You have an opportunity to be nice to somebody is giving you a good worker.
The ass off,
making $8 an hour,
he'll come up.
Wow.
I have got friends that don't tip,
you know,
they say Michael Jordan tip.
What they see is the worst temper in the world.
I heard that.
Oh,
for the Tetra Jordan man,
it's crazy.
$100 million off your shoes.
Yeah,
there's a lot of guys.
It's hard to like to leave.
They don't believe it.
No.
If I tell the story on the podcast,
my mother said my dad from losing a lot of money because she watched to do,
they were playing golf and I cheat on,
I cheated cough,
but this guy kicked the ball out looking around and make sure nobody saw it.
She goes,
the guy's a crook,
my file.
I was like,
what kicked the ball out?
And my phone was like,
I don't know.
My mother,
my mother is,
he kicked the ball out and did it like secretly if you do it in like,
you know like joking around like cheat and if you catch me,
I cheat.
If you play a board game or any golf in the Ouachita a really cheat and really
try to beat you and do it secretly.
But if you catch me why?
I'm just kidding.
I mean I'm,
I don't care,
but I mean I'm going to cheat at any game you play.
If it's a board game or I don't give a shit.
Yes,
yes.
But if you're doing it to really win and you're going to be secretive about it,
there's some things going on.
That's a little bit,
I went to jail,
by the way.
Ooh.
Yes.
Turned out to be a big,
Ooh.
Ooh,
well famous.
A white collar criminal.
Really.
Bernie main off.
Nope.
Shit.
Well,
Bernie Madoff,
Bernie Madoff.
My father's friend that came to my father's friend,
uh,
I think his name is Paul Derosa,
and he made a fortune and they said,
this guy can get you 20% of your money.
The first thing Paul,
the row.
So it makes it made his money the right way and the hard way.
It goes.
Really 20% call the police.
I said,
no,
no.
He's got the thing.
He goes,
really call the police.
Never seen it in my life.
I've been been this business my whole life.
You're telling me to make 20% on his money like that.
Called the cops said that way before he got caught.
Way before he got caught.
A lot of smart people lost a lot of money.
Steven Spielberg was
one of them.
Yeah,
a whole bunch of people that got ripped off a lot of rich people.
That was a huge fucking mistake.
Charities,
charities.
Oh yeah.
They catch up with you man.
Well,
he to catch up going,
no,
that's,
maybe that is the greatest scam.
I mean that he kept it going for 30 years.
If you paid attention to how many bankers have off themselves in 2014 no.
Ooh,
it's in double digits.
Yeah.
It's some weird number of bankers here.
All but when you're number,
when your life is a number,
when your life is only a number and you did it the wrong way and the Jig is up,
you know,
let's see.
Bankers and I'm killed.
They've killed themselves in 2014 it's some stupid number,
man.
There's like all these things going way back to 2010 2012 there's articles.
These motherfuckers are jumping off buildings.
I mean it's,
it's dark.
That's not how I'd go.
Well,
I don't want it to be a building.
You know what it is,
man?
Hell No.
It's a bunch of people that are like just super depressed about what they're
doing with their lives
cause cause of how they define themselves.
Did you,
speaking of dues,
jumping off bridges and buildings.
So you see homeboy on the one,
oh I think it was the one oh five or the one 10 tried to commit suicide.
When was this?
Two weeks ago.
Guess who's front row for it?
This guy coming home from training.
You saw the guy kill himself first of all,
I was in sitting there for five hours and travel cause yeah,
homeboy wanting to jump off.
So the cops spent in front of me,
blocked off everyone.
I'm sitting there like,
uh,
we're pro whatever,
an accident.
I'm waiting there.
People are getting out of their cars after an hour walk in and this one dude's
walking back and I go,
hey man,
how bad is it up there?
He goes,
Nah man,
look up.
Look at the bridge or your way.
He goes,
see that guy hanging off?
I oh shit.
He goes,
yeah,
he's trying to jump into traffic,
commit suicide.
So I literally sat there like this,
I'm not make us up.
The crowds started to chant,
jump,
jump.
After four hours I saw,
I look over this old lady in a key is going just doing iready there.
There is a time and after a while you got shit bro.
You're like,
you know I really have to go
are great movie.
That'd be a great movie.
A an hour and a half movie of you or anybody who's in traffic and you see this
mob mentality and you splice back and forth between this guy and these people
tell him to jump.
And the people that get
is this,
this is the guy up there again.
Selfies.
Yes,
I was in that man.
So did the guy actually jumped.
I think they talked him down.
Oh,
he jumped.
He might've just,
so what he did is the other side of traffic,
the other side of traffic was flea free flowing.
So he walked over to there to stop that traffic too.
And that it would literally,
I was there for five hours,
man.
The same thing.
I was in Boston and actually on my way to John Howard's,
Jim and I,
same thing,
traffic and people are taking selfies with the dude.
But before he's about to jump off these dudes,
these,
this guy was up there and other facetimed him though.
I wonder who the guy is who talks to them cause they have,
they have guys that go and
talk to him.
I'm not gonna lie,
I feel like I could talk him out of it.
I feel it.
Just let me up there,
Bro.
This fucking guy exists.
I'm just jumping [inaudible] New York City.
My mother and my mother has an apartment in New York City.
The woman across the hall,
there's a knock on the door.
I see these big Irish dudes with their firemen and these huge mustache,
just huge guys.
And the woman asked,
she goes,
hello.
And he and the guy,
the guy goes,
how you doing?
And she goes,
hi,
I'm fine.
And he goes,
were you sitting outs we use sitting out on your air conditioner?
And she goes,
um,
yeah.
And he said,
do you think that's a little unusual?
And she goes,
no.
And he goes,
you don't think sitting on your air conditioner 16 floors up is unusual.
And she goes,
no.
He goes,
you don't.
She goes,
oh,
and she just kinda collapsed.
They grabbed her,
put her on the stretcher,
you're coming with us on.
Really?
She was just right up.
She was a city this,
this guy wants to jump on.
This guy,
got to jump off the highway.
Hey Bro,
not that tall.
You're going to jump off your life and get a lot worse.
I mean,
maybe if your calculates first.
I know,
but at first it was just for attention.
Yeah.
Then we broke up with some girl know I can't go on and jumped up though.
People do jump,
but what I'm saying,
nobody dies first.
They cover themselves.
They,
oh,
it's your,
yeah,
your instincts kick in.
It's very rare that someone tries to stop.
It doesn't try to stop their fall.
What a horrible way to,
they've done studies on high enough Sam Shirt and it's only Sam,
Sarah,
and told me that,
that most of the people that jump and survive like the Golden Gate,
which is very rare,
all of them without a doubt say that halfway through they're like,
they're like,
oh,
why did I do this?
This was about,
yeah,
they all decide that's a bad idea.
I think golden gates number,
why know?
I have no idea.
Golden Gate I think is number one.
Number two is that creepy hotel and uh,
uh,
Denver in Colorado,
that one overlook where the fucking shining was.
Yes.
Yup.
Well Golden Gate was averaging 26 a year and that's where they put those nets
down.
There's a,
there's a documentary called the bridge.
Oh,
who's jumping off that damn thing,
that high 26 people a year and it's a lot of people and there's a 98% death
rate,
I think like 2% have survived that actual,
and they have to hit the water apparently at a certain angle where you break
your,
you know,
your break,
you hit it.
I think he hit the water 86 miles an hour.
Well,
if you hated life before and then I find,
and then you jump off a bridge and every bone in your body is broke,
you wake up in the hospital,
that what it is.
Every bone in your body breaks me.
Hit the water.
I guess it's not just that you water rushes into your rectum and your eyes and
but also you usually break your neck or your cause,
the,
the what it does to your jaw when you head and your feet and every,
ah,
because the surface tension of the water.
So the service happens to water.
When you,
when you hit it,
it,
it resists initially.
It's why if a car falls in the water it goes,
Ooh,
it's stops it the surface tension actually dense that will dent the car.
So your,
your feet break but then you got your chin or anything else that has to break
that surface tension as well.
You have a friend who went cliff diving in Ohio and he's telling me that he,
he jumped off some favorite famous cliff where everybody jumps and said,
it was unbelievable how hard it was when you hit the ground.
I was like a hundred feet.
Oh,
I only,
it was only a hundred feet.
First of all,
I jumped 40 feet and it was a nightmare.
I'll never do it.
I also jump,
I don't know,
it was 220 foot drop.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I'm not going to lie.
It doesn't seem that high until you look down.
You already fucking mind.
When you were up there,
your guts would turn inside out.
If you lean too much about it.
I'm just talking about homeboys jumping off the skyscrapers,
the way to go.
I feel like,
oh yeah,
that's the,
you just,
I don't know,
man.
It flying.
I don't want it do any of that.
I went,
I went parachuting and I literally was so afraid that I wasn't listening to the
guy on the radio in my helmet and I was holding the uh,
the,
that I was pulling on the guy.
So he,
I ended up,
I had a pair of hike.
I ended up landing a mile a mile away from where I was supposed to know because
I wasn't listening to him and how to glide my myself to where we should do that
stuff.
Boujee jumping,
skydiving,
go in the top of Sears tower,
cliff diving,
none of that base jumping where you're already doing something.
That's like waiting cons though.
The pros and cons.
Like I was in Costa Rica and my friend wanted to jump off this cliff.
It was like it was a rope and even a bungee cord and they go,
well yeah,
a lot of guys do it.
I'm not doing that.
You're looking at the pros and cons.
Crash is courage.
Courage is the funny thing because a lot of base numbers would say,
I could never get into a cage and fight another killer and some guys I can never
get on stage and do stand up courage as a compartmentalized thing.
Man.
There's pros and cons though.
My brain waves it.
Let's see.
Jumping on an airplane.
Well that'd be cool for about 30 seconds.
What if it's not cool at?
Wow,
look at that.
What is he doing up at the top of a skyscraper and your brain selfies to another
level.
Say you mean he's not,
he's not going to base jump.
He's just climbing that.
Yeah,
that is a,
that's bad ass.
No,
it's not.
That's retarded.
Yeah.
If you're an axial rock climber,
I don't look at that and go,
that's gangsta sweating my fucking too.
I'm sweating,
sweating these tight ass car picture.
Oh my God.
There's a guy above him taking that picture.
Jesus fucking,
so there's just climbing up that thing.
I'm sweating dude.
My hands or hands together quads are dripping when Lana phone or is that normal?
That's totally normal.
If you think,
if you just fuck that guy and his ass,
he would back up to your rhythm just so that you would knock him.
I gotta fuck you dude.
You're climbing too high.
It's just we're going to fuck and we're not going to do it fast.
Dude,
why?
You guys are nuts.
Why Tingling right now?
My Dick,
my dick is like pulsating and clamping.
I remember climbing a train.
I was holding onto the bridge in the red shirt,
upper left hand corner.
What the fuck?
What is that all my God.
Look how high it is doing please.
The wind blows.
Oh my God,
is he slept again,
pros and cons,
but if a wind,
you get a very cool view from high up con,
you done enough.
How come it doesn't freak you out when you look out the window on a plane?
I don't know,
Dude.
I,
I like that.
It's not like that.
It's weird.
I see on the freaks me out a little bit,
especially just that plane went missing when I get on a play,
not like say this bitch goes missing.
Who's a chance?
I'm such,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
I'm having a really hard time with this.
He too bad either.
It makes my stomach.
What is he doing?
Don't do.
Don't do this dude.
What are you doing?
Shit.
He's got something on his head.
Like what ways to go pro for sure.
Oh my God.
How far is he walking?
What a rush.
I am sweating so hard.
Oh my God,
this guy's crazy.
Holy fucking shit is awful.
How many of these guys here I'm getting,
I'm getting carsick.
Oh my God,
he's doing it again.
He's doing it again.
This is insane.
What's the name of this video?
Have you seen homeboys who climbed the,
uh,
the mountains though,
without any leashes?
Crazy Ukrainian climbing guy.
Oh my God.
That crazy.
You crazy guys.
I'm sweating.
I was
climbing a tree.
My friend Eric Wagner high school.
I was only maybe,
I dunno,
30 feet up high enough to really hurt my legs and I'm holding onto the branch
and I won't let go.
And he goes,
let go of the branch.
I go,
I,
I'm not going good.
He goes,
cause I was,
I was scuttling to get to the next to safer.
And so he's holding on and he's not afraid at all and I'm like this.
And he reaches over and squeezes my package.
She goes horrendous.
And I go,
Eric,
please stop doing that.
And he goes,
ah,
it's okay.
Or Ag and I go
was the most uncomfortable thing.
And I had to watch him and he's looking me in the eye and he goes,
and he's just squeezing my dick and balls.
Like it's one of those two words.
The clouds does it more than three times doing it.
You have to be as to get down to the ground.
When I say I literally,
I was going to,
I'm going to fucking kill you,
but it wasn't going to happen.
Did you let him go?
No,
he was bigger and stronger than anyone off.
Hey,
can come anyway,
sort of jamming you off.
I came,
but here's that.
But let me explain it to establish your position.
You know how I was like,
oh,
it doesn't seem that high.
The golden gate bridge on a spring break in college in Missouri.
My buddies wanting to go cliff diving and I'm afraid of heights if I didn't tell
him this.
So everyone's like,
let's do it and you don't.
I'm like,
yeah bro,
sounds awesome.
You just chicks around.
So we pull up.
I'm,
I'm thinking,
I'm like,
man,
I hope this isn't that high up.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like,
Dear God,
I hope it's not that high up cause I'm trying to act like a bad ass.
So we pull up on the boat and I'm like,
oh no,
look that bad.
And we get up there,
it's a beast to get up there.
We get up there and there's no turnaround.
You can't go back down.
You have to jump everyone.
Everyone's like,
yeah,
see a shop in the water.
Everyone jumps.
I'm last one
by myself sweating like I do not want to do this,
but I have to do it.
Then some guy down below goes to speak out of shit goes,
God,
you buzzy job already.
And I hear my friends in the boat go,
yeah,
so I'm like,
shit,
I have to do this.
I jumped the scariest thing ever done.
He was high as shit.
I had contacts at the time,
my head,
it's the one I kind of like,
belly flop,
head hits,
the water contact goes shooting out.
I was so scared and mad.
I literally didn't talk my friends for the rest of the day where he was like,
fuck that guy on the boat and was just upset.
Man,
if you're going to,
I've never told this story and I haven't told the story because it's a scary
one.
Um,
I've never told this story before,
but I'm going to tell you,
you don't know the story,
Joe.
Um,
last summer I went to south of France and I was with my wife and my buddy and
he,
the first day were there.
He goes,
we're going to go cliff diving.
And I said,
hmm,
I don't like that idea.
Okay.
It's a group of people.
One guy's the best horseback rider in the world,
whatever random stuff.
So we get there,
we get there and we're up there and it's,
it's,
it's the ocean number one.
Number two,
it's craggy rocks.
Number three,
it's very high.
And number four,
it's cold.
So I look over and my instincts and I go with,
so if we jump,
where are we supposed to swim too?
And the surfer who was from there said over there,
but I don't like the way the tide is washing up on those rocks.
So I go,
hmm,
that's all I had to hear.
Not going to do a pros and cons,
not going to do it.
The horseback rider jumps his,
his chubby girl jumps and guess who else jumps?
My wife,
mother and my children,
she just goes,
she talked about it.
What?
She's like,
I'm doing this to competitive chick.
She goes,
oh,
that girl's going to do it.
I'm doing it.
So that's my,
that's the mother of my children.
So guess what?
I got to go in and make sure she's okay.
So I jumped in and you're scared shitless.
I wasn't scared about jumping.
I was mad.
I was mad because I don't like the ocean.
I was mad because I didn't have a good instinct about it.
I was mad because I don't know that area.
And the mother and children decides it doesn't really matter about they see your
wife said fuck these kids,
I'm going to jump in this Rochelle,
my wife is fairly competitive and she's not going to let somebody pyre so,
so what right.
That's ridiculous.
Now I jump in and I know you and I are the same mine cause your cost is like
this too.
I jump in and I,
I swim,
we swim and now we have to go up on the rocks and the waves are hitting these
rocks.
So I said to Amanda,
I go,
we're going to have to ride this wave onto these rocks.
Let me go first so I can turn around and pick,
grab you.
No big deal.
I go and as I go and turn around,
I get hit with a second wave,
which just came out of nowhere.
It,
it,
it literally knocks me,
rolls me on this really sharp coral.
So my feet,
my hands,
everything's all full of blood.
My worst,
my worst legs are all full of blood.
She starts to kind of panic.
She goes,
Ooh,
I like that.
And the waves and stuff.
Cause I got the wind knocked out of me and I'm telling you right now,
I,
I grabbed her and she goes,
get away from me.
She thought I was going to drown her.
So I have to calm,
I'm calm a batch.
Well she just didn't want it.
She didn't,
she thought I was going to bring her down.
So just so I have to calm her down so it gets so bad cause I can't grab her.
I tried to get her back up on the rocks again.
Washed off again.
Okay.
So now it,
now I'm swelling at seawater.
She's swollen seawater and,
and,
and I'm literally,
I'm literally talking to me like this.
Like,
all right,
no big deal.
We're just going to,
we're not going to stay here.
Let's relax.
Let's just swim further out so we can get used to these waves.
Let's wait until it calms down.
It's crisis mode.
Christ,
you're telling them tall crisis mode.
And I realize that I'm panicked and I don't really actually have the strength.
I'm worried that I'm going to go,
I'm trying to,
I got to hold her up because she's,
she's strong.
And I think,
and I,
and I think I've got to get behind her,
but she's literally pushing me away now she grabs onto me and now I'm like,
oh boy,
I gotta I gotta get it together here because she's holding on to me and kind of
pulling me under the dude who's the surfer sees what's going on.
He dives in,
he grabs her.
I literally,
I'm holding her.
He comes up and I go take her,
take her like really calm.
I gotta take her cause she's panicking.
He grabs her,
he ends up having to put her on top of him and he lets the wave ride them up.
He gets his whole back and legs ripped up and he pulls her on shore.
So she's a bloody mess.
I ride the next wave in my feet,
my hands,
my body.
I'm all ripped up.
I'm all wrapped up for the rest of the day.
The vacation never been more angry,
so bad by the way,
that the helicopter that the rescue helicopter shows up and I,
and people all crowded around like what they saw.
Everything happen.
Then I'm full of blood and we're all full of blood.
The rescue helicopter comes up,
which is by the way,
some $20,000 fine or something.
We,
I grabbed Mandy,
I grab it by grabbing,
I'd go to my friends,
I go,
let's get in the car now they're going,
if they think it catches and figure out it's us.
So we jumped in the car and drive off.
That was the scariest I would,
I realized there was that the sea can take you so quickly,
you just go to the bottom.
Then I finding you,
we'll see you later.
Love.
And that shit happens all the time because people are,
if you don't know how to ride,
you know,
currents and waves,
if you're not used to it,
if we need a good swimmer,
swimmer is your life.
Yeah.
And I ended the swimmer.
You know what I thought about,
you know,
what's crazy to me,
into your family.
Think about me.
I thought about my kids getting without their mom.
I wasn't going back without,
without their mom.
I wasn't gonna Happen.
And that's way scarier than me losing my life.
I'd never had that expression.
If you didn't jump in.
Well that's exactly,
imagine if you didn't exactly,
but it sounds like there was a lot of space between her jumping in and a surfer,
the surfer in,
Oh my God,
he didn't know we were in Trump.
Ah,
oh my God.
That's why I jumped in and that's why you get a big fight after,
you know,
it was so,
I was thankful she was,
uh,
she was okay.
Whew.
That was a bad situation.
I don't even like telling a story cause it was cause,
cause of the feeling it gave me like I didn't feel it's not good to feel that
vulnerable to see is a scary bitch.
The ski is,
I don't fuck around the ocean.
My buddy who is something that's not fun.
My buddy used to have to take,
uh,
he would,
he would make his money by sailing boats in the winter for rich people up the
Atlantic,
which w during storm season sailboats.
And he was only one of the few people willing to do that.
And I say he got caught in a storm for 23 hours where the swells were going over
his body.
They couldn't,
they had to literally fly a guy from Alaska in a special boat cause nobody else
could do it,
could navigate the storm who tugged him in and he strapped himself and he was
getting hypothermia as the water and he couldn't see the waves at night.
He had wait to hear them because they would just come over the boat and the
whole boat would submerge that happened.
That happened for him.
That happened for about 10 hours.
Just kept some merging and they were out.
You keep 20 set from cap size and you've got to steer,
you can't eat the way you've got to be an expert.
And he was so,
so,
uh,
they were stuck out there and you're at the mercy of the C and a lot of times
you just get washed up on rocks and you die.
So we had to keep the rocks.
He got to keep away from the rocks and he had to keep the boat.
He had to deal with these insane waves at night where you can't see them.
They just,
another law rocks and the water and the water got to simultaneously worry about
both towns.
Right.
And you're in a metal boat for 10 hours.
It's a wood boat.
It's a wood blood.
Yeah,
it's a wood boat.
It's a sailboat.
Oh,
a sale.
You can keep that shit keyed that ocean shit.
And I said to him,
I said,
do you ever,
what kind of what?
You have a life vest?
He goes,
you know where life vests w what do you mean?
you look,
if you get knocked over,
you're dying,
you guys.
And and chances are life vest is going to keep you cold in a live longer than
you want to be.
You.
You're not.
And even if they can,
they can't come back and find you because they can't get you out back on the
boat.
They can't do it.
And that kind of weather,
you're probably injured anyway that those guys are hardcore.
Keep it,
keep Humboldt,
that fucking deadliest catch show you ever watched that show nuts?
Well,
those guys are up there just catching the craft.
How much town delicious could crabs be?
Somebody decided that this is what they wanted to do with their time.
If you fall in that water,
you got about two minutes before you have for your dead Hypothermia,
your dad,
it has to be better ways to make money.
I would imagine her in the sea last.
I'll shave my body.
Get paid by shame my body.
I'll Tan and take stories and become uh,
uh,
gay.
Uh,
a stripper.
You're already there.
You Click.
We did did it just for the adventure.
No.
Yeah.
Click.
Rita was a god damn crabber.
Oh,
I thought he meant he was a stripper.
No,
just fuse a crabber.
Yeah.
He went to fucking recently.
No,
when you was your day.
Yeah.
Well he's the toughest fucking wild man.
Decided he wasn't going to get a boat and just join and become a fucking crap.
It's another level.
He's a rugged man.
Think.
Yeah.
Guy Decides for an adventure.
He's going to join a fucking crab fishing boat.
And I'll ask,
you know,
who wouldn't do that?
Brennan Chop is tough as he as no interest hates nature.
I'd rather go work at Starbucks.
I love the ocean.
I love the ocean,
man.
I Love Surfing.
I love stuff like that.
Camping,
you can keep it.
You know what?
I'd love,
man,
I love being by the ocean.
I love looking at it.
I think those neighborhoods more mellow,
like neighborhoods that are near the ocean.
The problem is they're also more crowded.
Listen man,
whatever I'm of them I didn't think were discovery.
I got to do this,
this thing,
and I'm talking to the great white expert who did the documentary on those great
whites that breached the water South Africa,
and I said,
I say to him,
literally,
I'd never forget this.
I go there,
they're great whites in the Santa Monica Bay.
And he goes,
uh,
yeah dude,
a lot,
and I'm going to talk like that.
That's how you talk.
I know,
but for the,
for the story,
this is actually,
he said,
oh,
and by the way,
not only are there great whites,
I talked like me and my stories and shock Cousteau once said,
thank you for saying shock and he goes up.
I said,
yeah,
but little ones.
He goes,
we tagged the 21 footer about 200 feet off the Malibu shore.
Mm.
I was like,
where?
They say,
where are the fucking signs?
21 foot Great White Chevy with thins out there.
That's why I only surfed when there's a bunch of people,
so it has options.
I'm not even trying to be funny,
but I won't surf like with just me and another buddy.
I'll wait like this bunch of people around like,
all right,
do you know anybody who's ever been bitten while surfing or attack while
surfing,
surfing?
Nothing.
It doesn't always happen,
but you got to think that what you're doing when you're surfing is you're
mimicking what a seal looks like that.
Yeah.
Which is their main food source.
And on top of it,
you're doing it like a fishing lore where you'd go all the way to the shore and
they're right back.
Oh,
it's why our bodies,
why can't we make him so we don't look like fucking color blindness?
So everything looks the same,
but all right,
so make,
make them,
you know,
so if it's,
if it's black,
a seal looks black.
He said that when you were on a wooden board and you're wearing rubber for them,
um,
evolutionarily it doesn't make any sense that you're not their food source.
So when they do bite you,
it's almost always an accident.
However,
I told you the David Bland Story About,
Oh,
uh,
he decided part of his magic show and I don't think he heard it.
He showed it to me on his iPhone.
He went and bought a day off of shore,
um,
from,
I guess Los Angeles,
I think it was near Guadalupe island or something like that.
Uh,
he put a weight belt on,
held his breath.
He can hold his breath for longer than anybody in the world.
I held his breath and a Tuxedo real quick.
I don't believe the story.
Oh,
well,
he's got video on it.
We've got video on it.
They know this is real video musician,
magician,
this Israel video and he ate a banana underwater while these 24 foot great
whites just circled him and he put that on TV I had,
for whatever reason he wants to say he was going to save it.
Then he decided it didn't fit with us because it's a friend that gets 100% of
flights,
right?
Yea Man.
The Guy Bruce Jenner,
David Blaine story.
Well,
it just seems a little dude.
He did magic for you.
How freaky was that?
David Blaine was legit.
I went to a party at Calvin's house.
Kids party while I was there.
I was Deb.
No idea.
I don't have a kid showed up.
There's a jump castle.
David Blaine jumps out this bitch.
Hey Brendan.
David Blaine started doing tricks,
said some crazy shit.
Ever seen him.
He'll freak you out.
You think you think you,
you think you know magic and all I could focus was on the shoes.
He's doing all this magical,
I could focus on his shoes.
They were laced so tight.
I was like,
Bro,
is there some sort of,
it doesn't spend money I'll do from here.
That's not spend money.
I'm telling you the tightest,
literally impossible to get them any tighter.
It was all I could stare at owns black,
new balance jeans,
black,
black jeans,
black jeans will not sit black.
New balances does not wear clothes,
does not care about clothes,
does not care about money.
How come he is obsessed with,
with um,
examples of human suffering.
Like he reads all about all different things like the,
that did Bobby sands,
the Holocaust.
I mean,
he's always interested in human endurance.
He's fascinated with how human beings can suffer with dignity.
The,
the most,
the book that really changed his life was Viktor Frankl's book man's search for
meaning.
And David's always,
he watched his mother,
I'm not talking about school.
He watched his mother die of cancer.
And I,
I think it changed him forever.
And [inaudible] everyone,
my brother look like brothers.
They certainly do.
Could look like you were in my neighborhood,
my brother.
It look like his brother.
You could,
you could.
All right.
Whatever crazy about it.
So,
um,
where are you fighting our Lawsky again,
it's going to be in Vancouver,
Vancouver one 74.
Let me,
I always wanted to ask this.
So that's about how many weeks right now?
Six,
six weeks away now when you like gear up for a fight like that,
when,
what do you do differently than say what you're doing?
Like you're always working out,
you're always in sort of like maintenance mode,
right?
You were always in constant learning mode.
Constantly workings to keeping your conditioning up.
What changes between just training and then boom,
it's time to train for a fun.
Yeah,
the intensity for sure.
And then like sparring,
like tomorrow I'm sparring with this specific training partner to mimic our
Lawsky.
Usually I'm just going to rain train with Mark Munoz and pat come and stuff like
that.
And then now there's a game plan implemented,
you know,
so with,
with the rounds and I'm sticking to the game plan and stuff like that,
everything is way more intense.
My Diet's on point of people make my food now are on point.
Everything's really,
really serious.
What do you do differently with your diet?
What do you change as far as like what you eat?
Uh,
when I'm out of camp,
I usually,
I just like eat healthy in general.
Like I juice every morning.
He,
obviously people have their things against juice but juice every morning.
But if I'm out with friends,
like if I,
if I go out with Brian,
I'll have a cheese plate,
I'll have a beer here and there.
But now,
I mean,
I don't go,
I rarely ever eat out.
All my meals are cooked.
Everything's a Paleo Diet.
I don't do any breads,
nothing like that.
Yeah,
that's,
you've been doing that for a while,
right?
Gluten.
Yeah.
Big Difference.
Huge difference.
It's funny.
That's a touchy thing with people.
A lot of people were calling bullshit on that,
but there's some real science to people having a problem with men.
And the other thing is is like,
uh,
like friends asked me to go out and do stuff.
I won't do it like a Thursday night.
They're like,
oh,
let's go see a movie now.
I'm cool man.
I'm in,
I'm in bed by 10 every night.
Uh,
just kind of have to be right.
You have to be like super diligent about that kind of shit.
I have to be,
if I do anything less than I'll question myself on in the octagon you put
together your whole schedule as far as like what you do during the week?
No,
I have a coach Tony Jeffries who looks over the schedule and puts their thing
together.
Like I've already sparred twice this week,
but it just so happens this bad ass guy is in town and he,
he's a very,
it's great sparring.
He happens to be another heavyweight.
So we're,
we're going tomorrow and that was the,
I just found that out before I came here.
He's like,
Yo,
you're supposed to go wrestle and do Jitsu.
Not Anymore.
You're sparring five rounds with this monster.
What about like I'm on the track conditioning.
Okay.
Conditions another level.
So like,
uh,
I had,
I had strengthened condition today where it's kind of like implementing flat
three,
five minute rounds,
like circuit training and then tomorrow spar five rounds and then I'll go to the
track and they,
they,
they gave me a heart rate monitor and have to run these eight hundreds and then
as soon as my heart rate gets to one 40 I run them again.
And it's cool because by the,
by June 14th,
that week of I'll run.
It's crazy how fast they recover.
That's cool to see,
man.
That's interesting.
Do you wear one of those runs are in your chest?
I want to go to the best ones.
Right.
What are those four heart rate monitors?
Heart rate.
And those are the best ones,
right?
The ones and the rest,
they don't quite do it,
right?
Yeah,
they don't do it.
It,
it's,
I think it's called a Garmin.
You,
you're in around your chest and then you have the watch.
So when I run I can see it.
I coach is just like,
tell me what,
what's your heart rate at he,
they record everything and we'll say one 78 and then he'll like soon he gets to
one 40 you're going,
it's all about recovering,
about increasing the amount of time that you could run before you,
you know,
you hit a certain level and then once you hit that certain level,
dropping back and cutting the amount of recovery down as much as possible.
So if during the first week it takes you a minute and a half to recover,
that's what it is.
But by the six week it should be like 20 seconds.
It's cool.
It's cool to see,
you know,
like it gives you a definitive,
like you know,
you're in shape and what's cool is my coach is so on it that from last camp we
looked at when I first started camp for Mitch Reone,
what I ran my eight 604
hundreds in my recovery time compared to now.
And I'm already a step ahead of the game to run like a,
is there a day where you run like I dunno,
eight miles or something or is it mostly I liked to run long distance.
I love rock.
It's weird.
I love running long distance high.
Right.
I'll,
I'll just run for four miles and it's no thing,
but they have to cut back on.
It gets hard on your joints.
I'll run those 800 from my coach on the beach.
The beach.
I was going to ask you,
I'll do the beach.
Beach and dunes.
Dunes are great right off the dunes off PCH or some because you don't take the
pounding the,
exactly.
I see people running on the sidewalk and I just go,
God damn.
Do you not have anybody that you talked to tough on your body.
What about,
what about um,
uh,
biking and stuff?
Is that,
is that low impact or you sure,
yeah,
very low impact.
Low impact,
but you have to go such a far distance to get a good workout out of it.
Yeah.
Unless you're doing him.
Nothing really substitutes for running,
does it?
I mean you go swimming swimming's good too,
but that's also tough.
You can do a serious workout on a lot of different machines depending on the
intensity that you put out.
A spin bike to whoop your ass.
Fuck yeah.
If you have a good one,
if you have a good [inaudible] signs are beasts,
but for me,
limiting me,
I,
I think one of the purest forms of shown if someone's athletic is a sprint,
oh,
they're running form.
So for me it's just in my blood.
I,
I know if,
if I'm sprinting,
I'm running,
it just makes me know that I'm doing the right thing.
For other guys,
it doesn't make sense for other heavyweights they probably shouldn't do.
It's hard on their knees.
For me,
I have to do it.
It's not,
I don't have any injuries,
knock on wood,
nothing.
I've been running all my life.
I just said that's probably why you don't have the interest.
Cause he'd been running all your life and the human body is an amazing ability
to adapt to whatever you needed to do.
Yeah.
I think you were talking about,
that's how you're one of the people that has,
you don't get people get injured because they put a lot of weight on af in
between fights and they come back to training.
That's when you get injured.
You stand shotty,
they jump into camp and the body's like,
what the hell are we doing?
They blow out like their needs out of time.
We're three hours in there it is.
Sorry.
Do it again.
Thank you guys.
Easy talking to you guys.
And I just fucking flew by.
Um,
so I think we kind of talked about the UFC
is a post UFC fight.
Why keep showing the flying knee?
Great fight.
Yeah,
we talked about pretty much the entire a UFC,
right?
Other than a couple of the prelim fights.
But um,
well when are we going to see you guys again when we do this again?
Anytime you want,
you want to do the thing with Eric Silva and Matt Brown.
That'd be dope.
I'd love to see we find that.
I'd love to do it.
And that would be like the most disjointed podcast ever.
So for anybody listening in,
you're going to have to walk.
This is the companion podcast.
You have to be a real,
real fan of the,
you have to watch it at the fights.
Otherwise,
I'm going to say that at the beginning.
I want to say skip over this.
If you look at for it'll be or it'll be our fighter and the kid for that week.
Okay,
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it.
We're done.
Thank you to 1-800-FLOWERS for a sponsoring the podcast.
Um,
shit,
what is it here?
She male.
What is it?
Jamie has codeword Rogan buy one get one free available till tomorrow.
Oh,
hold on a second.
Is it Codeword Rogan?
I believe that's what you said.
Here we go.
I'll tell you in two seconds due to due to a next week,
we've got a lot of podcasts coming up.
Ladies and gentlemen,
just tell you that now.
It's not okay.
Don't ever say it Jamie,
unless you know it's j r e it's one 800 flowers.com and enter j r e that's one
800 flowers.com.
Enter J R he do not listen to Jamie.
Gerry put in Rogan cause it won't do Jack Shit for you.
And you say,
God dammit,
that's shelter fucked me.
Uh,
we'll be back next week.
I got uh,
author Nick Cutter,
a MMA fighter.
Tim Kennedy,
uh,
got a lot of people coming in next week.
Next week is going to be a long crazy week.
Got a lot of shit going on.
So,
uh,
that's it.
That's it for now.
We'll talk to you fucking freaks real soon.
Much love.
Thanks to everybody out there in podcast land the soliciting and join this
whatever you're doing,
where you do it,
whether it's commuting or sitting on a plane or sitting on your sitting on your
ass playing with yourself.
I don't care.
I hope you like it.
Thanks also to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t used the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off any end.
All supplements.
All right,
we'll see you next week.
Thanks everybody.